Hello 大家好 我是小珺
今天我们的嘉宾是Google DeepMind研究员姚顺宇
硅谷有两个很有名的姚顺宇/雨
一个之前在OpenAI跳槽去了腾讯出任腾讯的首席AI科学家
他之前也来过我们节目
那今天我邀请的是另一位姚顺宇
他此前在Anthropic
现在在Google DeepMind
我们从近期一系列的模型巨变开始聊起
那接下来就是我对顺宇的访谈
Anthropic作为一个公司来说
它能够实行这种
就是比较top down的机制
是一个很独特的事
可是这对于其他模型公司很难吗
很难 比如说OpenAI就干不了
就是Gemini也比较难
大公司和startup
它打法本来就不一样
因为startup重要的是make bet
就是我得我得赌一件事
我觉得大家现在就是
是每个人都是冲浪的人
本质上是一个浪
而不是你那个冲浪的人
但是反正就感觉AI这个事
本来也不太需要脑子
不太需要脑子
真的不太需要脑子
那需要什么
我觉得这个
这个行业就是最重要的特质
就是靠谱
就是做事细
然后对自己做的事负责任
这是最重要的特质
硅谷不是有两个姚顺宇/雨吗
你要不要先给大家介绍一下你自己
然后给大家科普一下
两个姚顺宇/雨的区别
啊
可以 对
就是我叫姚顺宇
然后
显然也有一个跟我几乎同名的朋友（姚顺雨，腾讯首席AI科学家，前OpenAI研究员）
我们俩主要履历也有一些overlap（重叠）
所以说可能看起来非常的难以区分
对 然后
我是我以前是做学物理的
然后我本科时候在清华
那时候做凝态理论
然后后来去斯坦福做理论高能物理
然后和量子信息啊
黑洞相关的一些方面
然后离开斯坦福之后
去伯克利
短暂的待了两个星期的postdoc博后
然后就离职了
去了Anthropic
然后在Anthropic待了一年
去年9月底10月初的时候
加入了Gemini
对 然后
如果大家非要区分的话
我觉得最大的区分就是
那个顺雨 他一开始就是一直都是做CS
就是计算机相关的
然后我其实
从某种意义上来说是个半道出家
对 就是我之前是做理论物理为主的
对
你们是不是好朋友
你们好像大学就认识
而且是一级的对吧（对）
他是一个什么样的人
你是一个什么样的人
评价一下他
你也评价一下自己（哈哈哈）
对对对我们本科就认识
因为我们本科是一级的
然后在清华
但他
当然他一开始就是学计算机的嘛
所以他在那个姚班
就是计算机科学实验班
然后我是学物理
所以我在机科班
对 然后后来他去了普林
我去斯坦福
这可能也是另一个有点令人费解的点
就是 好像这个普世世界里
觉得斯坦福应该是学计算机的人
该去的地方
然后
觉得普林斯顿是学物理人该去的地方
但我俩正好反过来
哈哈
所以说也可能产生了一些费解的事情
然后我俩其实也还真的挺不一样
我觉得他是一个比我有趣的多的人
我觉得我从他身上也是
在过去也是
能学习到了一些和我很不一样的点
比如说他可能花了很多时间去思考
比如在AI方面
他花了很多时间去思考
就是人和AI的交互呀
然后包括一些产品上的事情
然后我觉得其实对我来说
是一个很不一样的朋友
然后我也从他那学到了很多东西
你们之前在硅谷的时候
多久见一次面啊
你们现在是不是还频繁打电话
多频繁
我们在硅谷的时候见面确实挺频繁的
可能每几个星期吧
但是好像见面主要是为了凑一块玩
哈哈哈
玩啥
就是
真的就是纯玩
就是可能出去散散步
然后扯扯有的没的
然后可能有时候吃个饭
打个牌啊之类的
对 哈哈 对
然后他回去之后
其实我们也是
也还是经常会打电话
最近一次电话聊啥了
好像就是前一两个星期
啊
你怎么知道的
呃 可能就是
会过几个月
然后就catch up一下
大家过最近的近况吧 对
他是不是多次想把你拉过去
呃
嘶
哈
可能有这个意思吧
但是 但是
我觉得不关键
不关键 哈哈哈
你为什么不去啊
我觉得对我自己来说
我
没想清楚吧
嗯 我觉得多半是我自己的原因
然后
我也没有去任何
中国的地方
然后我觉得主要原因是因为
在去年的九月或者八九月这个时候
我觉得
那时候我离开
离开Anthropic
然后离开之后决定要去哪的时候 最大的动机是
我想学一些不一样的东西
嗯 对我来说
我可能就没有去考虑
没有没有
更着重的去考虑
说能够去领导一个项目
或者领导一个project之类的
我更多的是
是那个时候
更多的是优先去学习一些东西
所以那时候我选择去了Gemini对
我发现
你们两个老被放在一起比较和讨论
对你来说是困扰更多还是享受更多
我没什么感觉
然后
因为我这个人也不太关注社交媒体
所以我其实真的没什么感觉
嗯
因为那个顺雨
他之前在去年的时候说
AI进入了the second half
进入了下半场
这个成为了一个非常有名的观点
你觉得今天的AI
在一个什么样的时期
你能给它一个定义吗
对 我觉得对我来说
我可能
看得没有那么清楚什么叫做上半场
什么叫做下半场
或者说这个定义
一直以来对我并不是特别清楚
对我来说
确实现在AI进入到了一个阶段
就是我觉得
大家都已经开始不那么担心一件事
AI是不是能够做得到
而是担心这件事是不是被良好定义
对我觉得这是一个很大的区别
比如说我觉得一年之前
就是可能去年年初的时候
那时候
我在Anthropic
然后大家可能担心的事情还是说 哎
OpenAI这个reasoning（推理）做的这么强
我们有没有机会能够追上
然后有多大的机会能够超越它
大家还很担心这个事儿
我觉得现在就是在任何这
至少在Gemini OpenAI和Anthropic这三家当中
我觉得没有哪一家
会真的担心自己追不上
嗯
然后我觉得可能现在对
大家更难的事情是
是想明白要去做什么
这个是一个
我觉得是一个
是一个bet（下赌注）
但是也是
我觉得也是一个
很需要人的insight（洞察）的事情 对
那这也意味着模型的能力被拉平了
对不对 它变得同质化
变得商品化
所以模型没有很大的区别
就是在好坏上没有很大的区别
但是需要分化
我觉得从用户的实际体验上来说
这三家的模型是能够感受到区别的
但是难的一点是
过去这个区别在纸面上也能看出来
在纸面上是指什么
纸面上就是比如说像公开的
有很多种Benchmark（评估基准）
这种测量的规范
然后比如说大家以前能够去看SWE-bench
对对对能看SWE-bench
然后可能数学大家那时候会比像
简单一点的
AIME
然后难一点的像IMO那个时候感觉就是
你从纸面上就能看出来
哎 这个模型好像reasoning强一点
那个模型好像coding强一点
那个模型这个强一点
现在就是纸面上大家其实都比较相近
然后你去看那个纸面上的消息
比如看SWE-bench
你会发现 哎
好像好的会比不好的
可能高一个百分点
或者两个百分点
但其实大家都在80%附近
那个附近数字高一点
低一点其实是主要是noise（噪音）
就主要是噪声
而不是信号
对 但是从另一方面来说
大家使用上确实还是能体现
体验出区别的
我觉得 嗯
就我个人了解到的信息而言
Claude目前仍然是比较通用的
这种工具使用类的
Agent表现最好的
然后在纯粹coding的方面
可能最近Codex稍微追上了一点
把这个中间的gap变小了一点
然后Gemini
可能在纯的reasoning
然后和一些比较日常的使用环境下
可能目前还是比较好的
然后在
在coding和Agent上还处于一个比较在
在接近的这个状态
嗯 这些能力
他们是有意选择我优先发展哪个方向
还是说它就是好和坏的区别
就是它是能力问题还是意愿问题
我觉得呢
其实是有意愿的成分在的
尤其在过去的情况下
主要是意愿
就是当大家能从纸面上就看出区别的时候
那时候意愿肯定是占大多数的
因为可能
像Claude
就一直更看重这种使用工具的能力
嗯
然后包括coding
那
可能OpenAI还有一段时间非常看重reasoning
对当然它现在也开始看重coding了
那那个时候肯定是意愿会占大多数
因为你花你更有意愿的话
就意味着你能花更多的精力
去构建合适的基础设施
合适的infra
构建合适的数据
然后尤其数据
它是一个
从某种意义上来说
很花时间很花精力的事情
对
所以说那个时候肯定是意愿占主导
但是到现在这个时候呢
我觉得两方面其实都有
因为
嗯 其实因为纸面上大家都看起来差不多
然后其实甚至你就做一些
更内部的测试来说
这个数字也都变得
差别没有那么大了
然后这时候更难的事情就是
你该怎么去定义你的问题
定义你想要的行为
嗯
然后在这个事情
没有定义的那么清楚的时候
模型的很多差异其实来自于一些
其实是你想象不到的事
对
想象不到的事指的是
我觉得当然想象不到的事
就是你现在去问
其实我很难给你一个特别清楚的答案
可能过一段时间之后回过头来看
我才能给一个清楚的答案
但是我可以举一个
想象不到的例子吧
就是比如说 比如说退回往回退
可能一年两年甚至三年的时候
那时候如果你比如说去网上
取这些预训练的数据的话
你看训练模型就会发现模型在写代码
那时候当然没有这种Agentic的写代码
它都是写一段代码（嗯）
那时候你会发现
模型写代码会写得很好
但是可能那时候大家不知道为什么
但是这个里面意外的原因可能就是
你从网上随便的去
如果不做任何的数据的筛选的话
自然的这个
这个code data的质量就会比别的高一点
因为你去看网页
你会发现
GitHub的质量
是显著比别的正常网页要高的
在进入我们今天主题之前
我想先聊聊
我们最近模型的一系列的近闻
就是你看
最近大家都在讨论OpenClaw
嗯
你作为一线的研究员
你对这个新的产品形态是怎么看的
你周围有哪些讨论
我觉得有趣的是
我感觉这个事情在业外的讨论
好像比业内的讨论更激烈
哦 业内没有人讨论
业内有人讨论
但是我觉得对业内人来说
它并不是一个 嗯
特别令人惊讶的事
哦 怎么说
就是可能在公司内部
也有人已经做了类似的这种实验
或者这种demo
只是可能并没有作为一个产品
去很认真的宣发
然后把它打磨然后发出去
对 然后
当然事实情况就是
你去看这个OpenClaw
最早版本的GitHub的那个code
其实那个code也就
从某种意义上说
写的也不是特别的干净
但是我觉得它很重要的事是
它给大家展示了这种可能性
嗯 那可能展示这种可能性之后
OpenClaw的
作者自己也加入OpenAI
然后
那可能就是这些模型的实验室
或者说一些大一点创业公司会很快跟上
然后把这个东西打磨成一个真正可用的产品
嗯（对）所以我理解
其实在OpenClaw发布之前
Google就已经有人在做这个事情了
只是还没有发布
因为大公司的流程比较长
对 我我我的
至少我个人
所得到的印象是这样的
所看到的是这样 对
所以这种类OpenClaw的这种产品形态背后
本身说明了什么
在今年初的这个时间点上
我觉得其实
我觉得技术上来说
其实并不能说明什么
就是说OpenClaw这个产品
当然它依赖于模型能做的很多事情
但是那些事情的能力
其实并不是到今年年初
才准备充足的
我觉得可能在去年
就是像Opus发布4.5（Claude系列）
然后 然后
当然那时候Opus其实比OpenAI和Gemini 3
在tool use（工具使用）的能力上都要强一些
所以我觉得在那个时间点
其实你做这个事
这个事就已经是可以展示出来的
然后其实它
一开始发布也没有立即就火
它就发布了之后过一段时间才火起来
嗯
所以说
我觉得可能对我来说
技术上它并不是一个
并不是一个
就说那么令人惊讶的事
它是模型能力的自然溢出
对对对我会这样觉得
但是我觉得
它可能一个对于大家的惊喜
是说以前可能大家都没有意识到
它让大家意识到了这件事可以做
意识到什么
就意识到了这个
你可以 哎
让模型做很
就是
你可以控制很多不一样的模型
然后做很多不一样的事情
然后把这个事情汇总
汇总之后
做一个很长很长很长long horizon（长程任务）的这种
这种工作
我觉得可能
以前大家并没有
并没有广泛的对这个事产生共识呢
这个事情
给大家展示了这样一种可能性
你看从去年初火的是Manus
今年初火的是OpenClaw
就是从Manus到OpenClaw
变化是什么
是模型能力的变化
还是产品的变化
这也是个我其实一直没理解的事儿
嗯
就是
Manus和OpenClaw之间的质的区别是什么
是一个
我其实自己没太看明白的事情
说实话哈哈哈
OK
嗯 就是
或者换句话说
就是可能OpenClaw这个事儿火了
但是如果你要回头问我说
为什么Manus做不了这个事儿
我不明白Manus为什么做不了
可能只是它没做对
但是你看
不管是Manus还是OpenClaw
它们都选择了
Manus卖给了Meta（注：该收购目前已被撤销，我们节目录制于撤销之前）
OpenClaw卖给了OpenAI
这个现象说明什么呢
为什么它们都卖了
我觉得 嗯
我自己的感受是一个东西
如果要 嗯 长久的生存
还是需要考虑一些壁垒的
壁垒是模型
我觉得
至少目前来说
很多壁垒都是在模型侧
但是未来会不会产生产品侧的壁垒
我觉得是说不定的
就因为大家
市场上就是这都老生常谈的话题
就很多人就要谈论这个
什么数据飞轮啊之类的事情
目前来说
我觉得没有哪一个场景
真正的形成了数据飞轮
甚至AI纯粹原生的应用场景
我觉得目前除了Agentic coding
就写代码之外
没有哪个场景是AI真正原生的场景
变得非常成功
因为从某种意义上来说
Chatbot的其实是搜索的一个延伸
Chatbot是搜索延伸
对它为什么不是独立于搜索的
它是因为
因为你想
大家其实和Chatbot最多的交互是
我有一个问题啊
就问这个Chatbot
然后这个其实是搜索本来干的事儿
但是它带来的
比搜索要远强的一个事情是
它变得非常interactive（交互的）
就是它有交互性
你可以追问
然后它甚至可以帮你总结出一些
通过它获取的一些信息
帮你把它压缩成
浓缩成回答你的问题的那个信息
对 这个是以前搜索给不了你的
嗯（对）
但它当然就不是完全一样的需求
但是从需求
从大的需求上来说
是比较类似于搜索之前的需求
Manus和OpenClaw
我觉得都是现在最有名的壳
但是壳最后都卖给了模型（注：Meta收购Manus已被撤销，我们节目录制于撤销之前）
那是不是说明壳
还是难以逃脱模型的掌心啊
这个逃逸速度不够
不够快是不是
我觉得
我觉得壳在目前这个情况下活下来
有两种我大概能想象的方式
一种想象的方式就是像你刚才说的
逃得足够快
就是我增长速度足够快
以至于在模型公司反应过来的时候
我其实已经占领了大量的用户心智
然后在模型公司追你产品形态
的时候
我又自己演化出了自己的模型
我觉得Cursor就是试图在走这条路（嗯）
那Cursor其实在这种AI原生场景下
几乎是我能想到的创业公司里
增长的最快的啊
就算这样的公司
它现在也很有危机感
它有多有危机感
反正我的感觉是对Cursor来说
现在和Anthropic
已经进入了一个非常微妙的关系
就是
曾经他们是亲密无间的合作伙伴
Anthropic提供模型
Cursor提供产品
后来Anthropic自己有了Claude Code
Claude Code现在变得非常成功
然后
Cursor现在又自己试图做自己的模型
所以Cursor在努力的训它的Composer
所以说
我觉得都不用说未来
其实现在就是
它们已经处于一种比较竞争的关系了（嗯）
那如果在竞争中输掉的话
我觉得是比较麻烦的
因为代码这个事情
coding这个事情
其实它本质上是一种
服务于专业用户的
专业需求
是一种效率工具
效率工具很容易出现的一个场景就是
赢家通吃
我觉得这个是不管对Cursor
还是对Anthropic
还是对任何一些做做coding的公司来说
可能都是他们比较担心的事
嗯（对）
然后这是刚才说的
就这一条路
（要快）就是就是对你长得够快
你在你在别人还没想吃你的时候
就疯狂长
等它想吃你的时候
你足够大
另一种方式就是这市场足够的小
小到模型公司根本懒得去管
我觉得Midjourney就是这个例子
就是这个
这个市场小到可能
虽然你说Gemini努力一把
能不能做Midjourney
那个事可能花一些精力
花一些钱
花一些data是能做到的
但是足够小
以至于可能
Gemini就不是很会在那上面花时间了
看不上
对哈哈哈
我觉得那可能也是一种活下去的方式
对
所以哪怕是Cursor
今天也没有逃逸出模型的手掌心
有谁成功逃逸了吗
我觉得大的就我目前还没看到
小的可能Midjourney是个例子
当然肯定有别的例子
只是我还没看到
对 小的
我觉得会有
会有例子
Lovart算吗
我觉得他们有机会
他们有机会
反正就不能做那种通用的场景
我觉得这是founder要自己要决定的一件事
就是你要不要抱着1/10000的生存几率
去赌一票大的
嗯 还是抱着1%的生存几率去
先吃定一个小的事情
如果是你
你会怎么选
哈哈哈哈哈
如果是我
我内心肯定是想吃一票大的
但是我
真诚的想是
我觉得第一步是不能一步登天的
所以如果是我
我会选择去先吃一个小的
但是我会选择一个有想象空间的小的
你说OpenAI为什么要收OpenClaw
Meta为什么要收Manus（注：Meta收购Manus已被撤销，我们节目录制于撤销之前）
Google为什么谁也不收
啊 Google也收了
Google买了Windsurf的人
okay Windsurf
嗯
我不理解
哈哈哈
什么叫你不理解
说实话就是
我不理解
我觉得
我觉得Meta买Manus这个事儿
我觉得对他们来说
最大的用处就是
如果
抛掉花了多少钱之外
最大的用处是获得了一批很好的
在亚洲的的产品团队
在亚洲说明什么
因为
我觉得一方面就是
显然大家都知道
中国的AI人才储备还是很丰富的
虽然可能目前从技术上
纯技术上来说
中国的AI还没有真的追上美国
但是
显然AI中国是有很多好的人的
不管是从纯技术上还是从产品
产品上我觉得可能中国的本质上
人才是比美国要更好
对 所以对它来说
我觉得Manus成为了它在
新加坡的一个一个锚点
就它可以从那里吸引一些
比如说从中国的
或者是新加坡或者东亚的人才
然后我其实没有特别看明白
这个产品本身对Meta来说有多重要
或者换句话说
就是为什么Meta不能自己干这个产品
但是不管是Manus和还是OpenClaw
它事实上就是诞生于外面的团队
为什么
不是硅谷的这一帮研究员做出来的呢
你有没有反思过这个问题
对 对我觉得
嗯 对我来说这个问题
其实
我觉得一个公司一旦变大了之后
它的负担也变大了
就说我可能作为一个研究员
然后我们可以做一些很
看起来很有趣
很有特点的产品
但是我一旦把这个产品去公开给公众
那要负责的事情是非常多的
第一你这个产品不可能说一上线
然后告诉所有用户
你得再去买一台电脑干这个事
否则它就有可能会获得你电脑上
所有的权限然
后把你系统搞崩
嗯
这就作为一个大公司来说
你比如Google
Google是不可能提供这样的产品出去的
对吧 嗯
然后所以你产品要花很多时间打磨
然后你要确认
法律上它没有一些风险
然后用户上又不会损坏自己的品牌
然后
你如果把它送出去了
你可能还要给它
就是比较固定的一些资源
去serve这个模型
或者serve这条
这条产品的线
所以对对
对大公司来说
我觉得还是有挺多负担的
但是对于个人来说
无所谓啊
就是我反正是一个开源的项目
我代码垃圾又如何
你帮我来一起写吧
对吧哈哈哈对
我觉得不管是Manus还是OpenClaw
它其实指了一个方向
就是
这也是2026年的某种叙事的可能性
你对2026年是什么
怎么样思考和预期的
我觉得其实有太多的可能性
然后对我来说
从模型能力上来说
我觉得
模型 就是 我有时候特别爱说这个口号
就是我觉得模型做到
train with finite context use as infinite context（训练是有限的，但用起来像无限的）
就是换句话说
就是你用有限的这个
这个context length（上下文长度）去训练它
但是可以在使用的时候用非常非常长
甚至接近于无限的context length
我觉得这件事儿
今年是是有机会能够做实现的
然后这件事情实现之后
我觉得会解锁很多新的应用
也会因为因为举一个最简单的例子
就是 你有可能可以让这个模型
跟你持续的交互
然后持续的获得你的信息
然后它在运行的过程中
会持续的根据当前的场景和你的会话
可能把那些它觉得不重要的信息扔掉
然后就成了
就是大家梦想中的个人助手
对我觉得这个从技术上来说
我觉得这件事是会
今年是无论如何是会实现
但是当然当然
我觉得现在大家没有达成共识的是
技术上怎么去实现这个事
嗯
显然是有很多技术路线
但是现在我觉得更多是属于
在尝试哪条路线能够跑通的同时
可能有好几条路线都能跑通
那我们到时候就就要去实验上去测
在用户常用的使用场景下
哪条路线的的效率是最高的
对我觉得现在更多处于这个阶段
而不是说大家没有想法的阶段
就大家有想法
但是要确定哪个想法是最后的想法
站在这个2026年的Q1作为
一个一线的研究员
你觉得模型的进步速度在放缓吗
我觉得完全没有（完全没有）我觉得完全没有
它的速度曲线对比25年
24年的变化是什么
嗯 这个很难量化的说
因为就是你得给一个标准
我才能量化的告诉你
因为如果你给的标准是比
如说 我就看在某一个Benchmark上
比如说随便SWE-bench上
它每一个月涨多少个点儿
那这个事儿是肯定会变慢的
因为根据定义
这个Benchmark最高就到100%
嗯
所以你越接近
那肯定是越跑越慢
但是这可能并不代表
用户体验这个模型的能力增长变慢了
因为可能从50%到60%
它可能感觉哎
好了一点
但很有可能
比如说从70%到75%
它发现好的比50%到60%那个还多
嗯
这是完全有可能
如果是80%到90%
90%到100% 这个感受会更显著
那也不一定
因为可能过了
可能到80%到90%
用户就发现没有任何区别
甚至还变差了
你说完全没有变慢
你是基于什么标准
我觉得是基于
我个人作为一个研究员的感觉
就是
我个人得到的感受是
这个模型学东西的能力越来越强了
以前可能让模型学会
干一件事情需要动很多脑筋
但现在可能不需要动那么多脑筋了
最重要的是
你是要把这问题定义清楚
然后想清楚怎么去构建合适的数据（嗯）
当然数据
现在数据就更广泛
指向环境之类也都在包括在内了
然后
剩下的事情
好像很多时候是顺其自然的了
对
学习能力变强是为什么呀
模型的学习能力变强了
我觉得可能一方面
原因可能有很多方面
但我觉得可能一方面是因为预训练
其实在过去的几个月里
我觉得还是越来越强了的
预训练
对对
模型的预训练
其实在过去几个月里还是变强了（嗯）
我觉得这个可能是一个
从某种意义上来说比较有争议的事儿
因为几个月以前
我觉得就是
很多人已经在讨论预训练的
这个Scaling Law（缩放定律）
是不是已经到头了
嗯
我的体验是没有
而且我的感觉是
在未来的4个月
也没有看到到头的迹象
嗯
觉得到头是为什么呢
我觉得嗯
我我我
显然不知道
大家觉得到头的原因是什么
因为我自己没觉得到头
但是我觉得我的猜测是
一个人觉得一个规律到头了
无非
以下两种情况
啊
一个情况是
他觉得这个规律的适用范围到头了
啊就可能
就可能
从根本上讲
Scaling Law
就是没有办法无穷延展下去的
which有可能是对的啊
但是这是一种猜测
就是这个人可能觉得这个
这个规律适用范围到头了
另一种可能是
这个人觉得
这个规律
其中的有一个条件不能满足了
比如说他觉得数据就已经撞上墙了
那我完全没有把它延展下去嘛
另外一种可能性
但其实还有第三种可能性
第三种可能性就是其实
他这个工作哪里有一个bug
他自己没发现
所以他觉得到头了
哦
我觉得从我的观点
从我的观感上来说呢
我觉得
可能绝大多数撞到墙的人
是因为第三种
是因为有bug
是哪种bug
我觉得
bug是有很多种可能性的
比如说一种可能性是
你Scaling Law做的时候
一些科学的假设没有做对
比如说你选什么样的token horizon
就是每一个大小模型选什么样的
这个期待的训练的数据量
然后这个数据量
这个数据是从哪里选
然后
有可能这些比较科学的选择
没有选清楚
是一种可能性
但我觉得还有一种可能性就是
纯粹就有个bug
这个其实在业界我觉得也不惊奇
很多时候
修好一个bug
带来的进展
是远大于一些很神奇的技巧的
对
然后当然还有另外的情况
刚才给的这两种例子
反正是我见到过比较多的情况
那你们的bug怎么办
你们怎么解决bug问题的
我觉得对
我感觉这更像是一个信念的问题
因为当你遇到一个bug
你觉得它不能解除
你就会说这个到头了
当你遇到个bug
我觉得哦
这个肯定可以解决
那你就觉得这还没有到头
因为肯定每个人都要遇到bug
我觉得我觉得
这可能就像你说的
就是
其中有一些比较信念性的东西
但对我来说
更重要的一件事是做事系统
就是当你一个事情
和你预测的不一样的时候
你能不能系统性的排除各种可能性
这个我觉得是一个很重要的事
嗯
这个
是我觉得Gemini和Anthropic做的比较好的事
就是
尤其在预训练上
就是说当某一个尺度上的行为
可能和你想象中不一样的时候
大家能够去去设计合理的
我们所谓的ablation实验（消融实验）
合理的这种实验
能够看出来
测你的一些
想象中的可能的因素
是不是真的因素
我觉得这个
做问题的系统性才是关键
嗯
你觉得
模型能力还能提高
那它的驱动力
数据算力
算法
你觉得它的驱动力主要来源于哪个
我觉得其实都有
但是从某种意义上来说
数据和算力两个事
其实是很强关联的一件事
数据和算力嗯
对因为
你算力上去了
自然就会吸到更多的数据
数据上去了
你就自然需要更多的算力
对 然后
算法上来说我觉得
算法作用往往是有一个相变的
就是算法有一个阶段
是你完全没有搞清楚该怎么做
那个阶段就算法会非常非常关键
因为你没有完全没有搞清楚怎么做的
时候你可能就完全没有办法scale up
然后可能就卡在那了
但是在某一个点
你可能发现了
算法当中最重要的一件事
那它可能一下就变成了
从完全不能做变成了能做
然后之后算法的提升
更多的是一种比较平滑的提升
就是
它可能从某种上提高了你计算效率
或者使用数据的效率
对然后
我觉得就举例吧
就比如说从语言模型的预训练来说
那可能这个算法上的这个跳的过程
就是
就是发展出Transformer这个事情
但Transformer发现之后
更多的都是慢慢就是平滑的
让它的效率
或者你使用data
或者使用算力的效率变得越来越高了
对
所以现在的驱动力是算力和数据
我觉得在现在比较清晰的框架里面
主要的驱动力是算力和数据
清晰的框架是指
比如说预训练和后训练
不管是基于强化学习的后训练
还是基于supervised learning
就是监督学习的后训练
比如在这两个就是比较清晰的这种
这种paradigm（范式）下
确实算力和数据是主要的驱动力
但是不可否认
可能有别的方向可能驱动力失算了
嗯什么意思
举个简单例子
比如说多模态生成
嗯
那个
我觉得可能就是一个算法上来说
没有太想清楚的事
所以那个还是个科学问题
还没有解决
对
但是语言已经不是科学问题了
自然语言的生成
我觉得目前
这条技术方案撞到头之前
我觉得在科学上是比较清楚的
但是工程上
也还有很多很多很多要做的事
你觉得预训练还能提高多少
通过预训练提升模型能力
还有多少
多长的路可以走
可以预期到
人就是这样
就是当你没有撞到头的时候你
其实不知道这个路有多长
我能
我能看到的就是现在还没撞到头
但我也不知道哪天会撞到头
如果真的让我去估计一个时间线的话
就像刚才说
我觉得4个月
接下来4个月是还是会继续有进展
但是AI这个方向
没有人能预测4个月之后的事
嗯 所以过去几个月
你在看预训练和模型能力的时候
你还是很兴奋的
这是你周围的普遍的心态和状态吗
我觉得是的
这是在Google一个小环境里面
还是说在整个硅谷的环境里
我觉得很难说在整个硅谷
因为硅谷是个太大的地方
可能做产品的人对产品很兴奋
对吧做产品来说
对他们最兴奋的是可能有OpenClaw
嗯
但是对做模型的人来说
可能就是
我们会对这种模型进展更更兴奋一些
嗯
我觉得
呃
对于做模型的人来说
兴奋是一个共识吗
在过去4个月
我个人认为是的
哦 我个人认为是的
至少在我能接触到的范围内
我觉得在
Anthropic和Google大家
或Gemini大家可能想的更多的是
我们AI会不断地进展下去
很快我们就要被替代掉
替代掉之后我们该干点啥
呵呵 而不是模型撞到头了该怎么办
呵呵呵
说到这个问题
为什么
在过去几个月
coding的发展速度是最快的
为什么是这个场景啊
我觉得coding这个场景
首先coding这个事儿
不只是在过去几个月发展最快
我觉得coding这个事儿
其实
从Claude 3.5 (new)
或者外界有人管那个叫Claude 3.6（嗯）
从那个之后
一直都处于高速发展的状态
然后我觉得
那个是去年初
还是前年底
那个是前年的10月份
前年10月份
对对
应该是 有可能10月份或者11月份
但是差不多那时候
从那之后
我就一直都处于高速发展状态
我觉得coding这个场景有
两个最大的优势
第一个优势就是它的reward signal（回馈信号）
就是它的那个回馈的信号
是很好定义的
因为
比如说你去
比如说像software engineer（软件工程师）这种task
有时候经常情况就是
我需要写一个code
实现一个feature
一个特征
（嗯）这个特征需要的是某些输入
会得到某些输出
这就是一个很容易能够
很容易能够测试的事情
所以它的回馈信号非常清晰
你输入和这个输出能够对
那就说明你的实现是成功的
不对那就说明不成功（嗯）
但这只是一个例子
就是在这种和写code相关里面
有很多很多
很多这样良好定义的回馈信号
然后另一个比较大的优势是
coding的数据有一个非常天然的基础
这个基础就是GitHub
GitHub上汇聚了过去几个大概的
几十年
很多优质的程序员所写下的代码
然后从那些代码出发
是可以构建出非常非常非常多环境
我觉得这两件事从模型的角度上来说
是为什么coding可以做得很好
当然我觉得从产品上来说
还有另外一方面的原因
就是coding
这个产品的使用需求
其实是从某种意义上说
是比较单一的
它不像你去做一个像社交软件
或者游戏
可能每一个人都有不一样的品味
然后你可能很难
就是能够满足每一个人的需求
那可能就是需要推荐算法
但是coding这个事
好的事情在于优秀的程序员写代码
其实风格是比较类似的
什么风格
简洁干净
就是 对 就是好的代码是
（不脏）是有一些共同的标准的
比如说像你说的
就是这个代码简洁
结构清楚
适于未来的开发
然后有合理的抽象
当然还有别的很多标准
但是我觉得好的程序员往往是有
有比较共识标准的
对这件事
所以这件事从产品上来说
其实让coding这个产品变得更简单了
你现在的工作
百分之多少会用Claude Code写代码
它能帮你提高工作多少倍啊
你问了一个我差点会被开除的问题
Google不能用Claude Code
哈哈哈哈哈哈啊对
就是我觉得 对我来说
一个保守的估计
可能90%的code是模型产生的
但是可能就是
我需要花很多时间去去看这个code
是不是写得合适
写得合理
是不是真的是我想让它写的
然后我觉得有了AI辅助工具之后
可能写code的这个事儿
最重要的地方变成了
你怎么去设计
你怎么去设计你这个code的逻辑
然后它需要和哪一个
文件相关联
然后需要做某哪些事情
然后你需要给这个模型
可能给一些合理的context
就是说哎
比如说这个code
你可以做一个reference(参考)去看一眼
对真正去输出code
我觉得模型比人的能力强太多了啊
所以说对我来说
你要实际去数
有多少行code是我自己手写的
有多少行code是模型写的
我觉得保守估计模型写的超过90%
不保守的可能就是99%或者100%
剩下10% 是它不能写
还是为什么你没有让它写
保守估计90%
给我自己点面子
哈哈哈哈哈
我觉得它不能写
而我能写的部分已经越来越越来越少
越来越少越来越少了
过去可能是什么样的
是它不能写的
我觉得
很早的时候就是可能在一年半以前
那个时候
市面上其实说白了
就是只有Claude一家能够
能够真的写这种软件工程code
那个时候
模型还是能体会到很多很多缺陷的
比如说
它有时候可能写code
就只关注这一个文件
它就不会很关注那种多个
多个多个文件之间的关联
然后如果一个比如说一个class
它的定义其实藏在很多层以后
或者说它其实没有直接被套在这个
这个直接的树里面
可能这个模型就找不着
现在我觉得这个事已经越来越少了
呵呵
真的越来越少了
作为一个researcher
你的写程序的工作量
能够是过去的多少倍
因为从写code的角度来说
是比较能难量化这个事儿
但是如果说从比如说我做实验
然后实现一些idea的效率上来说
我觉得可能比起一年甚至一年半以前
可能都是20甚至50倍的这种加速
对因为现在模型真的变得
就是可以很离谱
就是你可以同时开好几个
然后你好几个idea
然后同时的去试
甚至有些时候
这个模型可以帮你监控一些实验啊
监控一些结果之类的
所以说
还是真的是一个挺挺大的效率提升
对但是
如果从个人工作时间上来说
我觉得它好像让我工作时间变更长了
这是为什么
就是
因为开发的速度变快了
越试越想试
有越来越多的想法要去试
所以说感觉以前你可能存在说哎
你有一个东西
比如这个文件
以前没见过
你可能自己看你搞的不是很明白
那肯定你要去花时间去找那个人
然后你约
那个人 可能就几个小时之后
但现在就不是
你就看到这个文件
你不懂拿去问一下Claude或者Gemini
Gemini可能5秒钟就告诉你结果
你就接着干了
哈哈哈 所以说从工作时间上来说
我觉得好像工作时间反而变长了
而且工作的密度也变高了
好Google已经不是那个Google了
是吗
不是那个
可以养老的Google
不是那个work life balance的的Google
我感觉在GenAI（生成式人工智能）这个领域
没有谁可以养老
哈哈哈
所以你现在早几晚几啊
我一般可能早上9点钟开始
到公司吗9点
早上9点可能先起来看一下邮件
然后看一看我前天晚上实验
然后到公司可能一般10点左右
然后啊晚上
如果我一个人在美国的时候
我可能就会待到可能10点11点这样
当然如果我家人在
我老婆在的话
我可能就会早一点回家
但是在家反正也是干
所以我觉得在GenAI这个领域
没有谁是在躺着的
除非就是
你已经完全对技术没有兴趣了
对自己没有追求了
那你躺着其实也没有人管你
但是我觉得大家还是比较self-driven（自驱）
就是还是自己想干对
你觉得其他的领域
会出现更多的这样的Claude Code的时刻吗
coding之后会在哪里爆发
你问了一个好问题
我要是看清楚了
我可能已经出去创业了
哈哈哈哈哈
对但是但是
确实就是除了coding之外
我们已经能看到
就是对很多
别的方向已经产生大的影响
但只说那些方向
可能并不是一个好的
这种市场上的方向
比如说
好多现在的做基础科学的研究
比如做数学啊
做理论物理
好多人
其实已经就大量的开始用AI工具
因为过去你可能像我们做AI研究
其实很像
就是说你可能想到一个想法
你想跑一个数值 学物理的人
又不是很会写code
光学明白怎么打开这个编译器
把code跑起来
可能半天已经过去了
现在就没有这个烦恼了
就是你现在想试
5分钟之后code写完了
你就可以开始试了
然后甚至像Gemini Deep Think发布之后
有很多这个基础科学的研究人员
就把这种
比如说数学推导啊
数学证明啊
然后甚至就是
去看这些不同的这种文章
然后归纳
这些事全都交给模型了
所以说已经
我觉得
对除了coding之外的方向产生了影响
当然就是那些基础研究
你可能很难
就是变成一个万众瞩目的事情
除非你就真的发现了
一个以前人都没发现的
很妙的理论
比如AI产生了爱因斯坦理论
这样级别的东西
那可能会变成万众瞩目
但那个时刻可能还没到来
但是影响是已经在产生了
哇 AI好神奇啊
它为什么首先上来做的都是
人类觉得最难的那部分工作
我觉得这是一个特别好的问题
就是我觉得过去的 嗯
在我人生的阶段里
大家往往会觉得
最
智力上有挑战的工作
反而是那些比较理性的事情
比较客观的事情
嗯
比如说数学
比如说写代码
比如说做AI研究
还有科学研究
对
就是越是这些事
其实AI越容易做好
因为你一旦想清楚这个事怎么去评价
你就知道怎么训练
人为什么比较难呢
（我觉得）你看人都是智力分配最高的那部分
人做这些工作
对
但是可能未来就不是这样了
哈哈哈我觉得未来
未来会怎么样
未来其实会发生了一个改变
就是那些AI
就是有很多AI其实没有那么容易做
但是反而是人可能做比较好的
比如说做产品经理
我说实话觉得
做一个好的产品经理
是一个我现在想不明白
该怎么训练AI去做的事
这是为什么
没有标准
没有标准（没有刻度）
就是什么叫做一个好的产品
我其实想不太明白
没有一个很客观标准
你一定是做出来了之后给人用了
你才知道它好
那大家才会说它好
对我觉得
那个就是一个回馈信号很不明确的事
那个我就不知道该怎么去训练AI做
对
程序员什么时候会被彻底取代吗
会有会有这一天吗
嗯
我觉得这一天会来
但是它不会是一瞬间的来
就不会是程序员都还在
过了一个晚上
第二天程序员全被开除了
不会是这样的
一定会是一个渐变的过程
但是
大家现在已经看到这个渐变的过程了
因为有一些公司已经开始开始裁员了
对我觉得
从某种意义上来说
AI是一个
它当然是一个很好的东西
但是从某种意义上来说
它可能也是一个
很不幸的事
就是AI是一个很centralized的technology（中心化技术）
它会让少部分人变得更强
但会让大部分人失去
他们的独特价值
对所以说我觉
得对于传统的软件工程来说
最后变成结果可能就是
现在1/1000的人 干了过去所有人的工作
拿着现在100倍的工资
那你对程序员有什么建议
我觉得
哈哈哈我觉得可能
接受新事物吧
就是我觉得很重要
我觉得
未来程序员可能很重要的一件事是
怎么和AI去有效的协作
嗯 做
比如说有很多事情是AI可能做的
不是那么好的事儿
比如说怎么去
合理的设计一个事情的实现方案
然后怎么样设计
让它可能跟这个公司
未来的发展比较契合
那这些东西
可能你很难去告诉一个模型
让它理解这些事儿
那这些事儿可能还需要人去做
但是可能像具体的
就是很具体的
就是像过去很多程序员做的工作
是你的经理告诉你实现这个方案
下周五之前给我
我觉得这样的工作
未来可能就不会不会再存在了
那1/1000的程序员会是什么样的程序员
他们的特质是什么
1/1000是个虚数
我真的不知道是会是1/1000
还是1/10000
还是1/100000
也可能是1%
你不要那么悲观
我是一个著名的悲观主义者
所以说也不要太那什么
然后
我觉得
未来好的程序员
首先他肯定是从技术上来说
他一定是会是非常强
因为如果你技术上弱
那没有什么道理
AI不能取代你
但技术强可能不会是唯一
就不会是一个必要条件
它可能是个充分条件
另一个事情我觉得会很重要的
就是你得能够理解你的这部分工作
在一个大的组织或者一个大的公司里
该去怎么
怎么适配进去这件事情（嗯）
这件事情可能也是一个重要的
嗯 然后
然后当然还有可能别的很多事情
比如说
这个人的规划能力是不是足够强
他规划能力强的话
他肯定可以同时把这个大的
一个很复杂的事情
拆解成很多相对较小的事情
然后交给不同的AI去做
但是现在看这三种能力是重要的
可能AI还不能完全做
不代表6个月之后不能
可能6个月之后你过来问我
我发现最后一个事AI已经能干了
那就只剩下两个事
再过6个月
可能剩下两个也能干了
那可能我就我的回答就会变得更悲观
所以说
没有人能预计6个月之后发生什么
我只能说从现在的观点来说
刚过去的那个春节
很多人关注另外一件事情是Seedance
Seedance会让Google焦虑吗
我觉得其实
有可能有
但是这个焦虑的情绪
目前还没有传导到我这儿
可能让Google DeepMind
负责多模态生成的团队
会有一些压力
但是如果你要问我的话
我觉得
我可能不觉得他们有什么可焦虑的
就是我觉得
并没有体现出什么范式上的改变
更多的是我觉得字节在
不管是这个产品的效果
还是可能在数据上啊之类的
这些细节会做的非常非常好
我觉得确实是
字节过去在多模态生成
一直以来都有比较强的优势
但是我觉得至少我个人
没有体会到
它是一个范式上的变化
那可能
就不足以说让大家非常的焦虑吧
对但是肯定是有压力
对
Seedance它的产品能力来自于模型能力
还是产品能力啊
我没在
字节干过
所以我也不
知道具体的细节
但是你要让我猜
我觉得可能模型还是占大头的
嗯
模型能力的好来自于什么
来自于数据
因为算法可能没有本质创新
我觉得算法
首先就是因为刚才多模态属于
咱们说的就是还属于那个
科学问题
多模态的生成属于科学问题
对多模态生成
还属于一个比较科学的问题（多模态理解解决了吗）
比生成肯定是要更系统
有更系统的理解了
但是比起text token来说
肯定还是没有那么的
范式还没有那么固定
我觉得生成上可能就是
因为它是一个还没有
范式上还没有固定的事
可能每家用的技术都会有一些大的
或者小的区别
然后嗯现在更多的只是能看到
说效果上来说
可能字节和Google DeepMind属于
在效果上来说
做的比较好两家
嗯 所以它可能也是来自于细节
做的更好
对你如果要让我猜
我会猜数据
数据
你要让我猜我会猜数据但是
就我也没在字节干过
所以也是我硬猜的哈哈哈（嗯）
你怎么看从Google去字节的吴永辉（字节跳动大模型团队Seed负责人）啊
我何德何能 哈哈哈
评价永辉我觉得我觉得
我当然过去没有和
永辉一起工作过
所以我
其实
真的不是很能给什么很好的评价
很客观的评价吧
就说但是我觉得我去了Gemini之后
看到的更多的是永辉好的一面
就是我觉得他是我通过去看他
偷偷去看他以前交过的代码
以及他带过的项目
我的感觉是他是我见到的少数层级非常高
然后人也很senior
但是还有很强的技术能力
我觉得是非常非常少见
所以我觉得
我觉得
我可能是还没到能够评价永辉的这个
这个水平呢
但是要让问我说的话
我觉得永辉是非常非常强的
你说站在2026年的这个Q1拍一张快照
你觉得中美的模型能力
差距是在放大 还是缩小
差多远
我觉得
嗯
如果现在拍一张快照
去看过去一年的发展趋势
或者过去一年半的发展趋势吧
显然
这个中美之间的gap是越变越小了
但是最后这个gap会不会完全弥合
甚至中国超过去
那我觉得是一个不清楚的问题
我觉得对中国的AI的研究员来说
研究机构来说 也是一个机会
然后
我觉得一个很真实的事儿
就是
中国确实在实际的算力资源上来说
是占很大劣势的
但是这个很大的劣势
可能反而逼出了一些有趣的事儿
比如说中国的模型公司
其实对distillation（蒸馏）别人很在行
对
最近Dario（Anthropic联合创始人兼CEO）不是点名了3家公司蒸馏它
我觉得其实可能是一个蒸馏这个事存在
是一个心照不宣的事实
但是我觉得蒸馏它也有不同的方式
就是也有硬蒸和和聪明的蒸
两种不一样的选择
嗯
什么叫硬蒸
硬蒸就是最举个最简单的例子
就是
我从Claude里面取出一堆它生成的Token
然后强行在上面做训练
这个如果干这样的事
我就觉得
首先商业上也不是很道德
然后智力上来说也比较愚蠢
因为干这个事儿的公司
其实本质上来说
它体现出来的一件事儿
就是它其实都不知道自己想干嘛
它能干的唯一一件事儿就是抄别人
然后让自己的模型
数据上能看的好看一点
对但本质上就说明它
自己都不知道该干嘛
这是硬蒸
但是
其实蒸馏也有一些很有趣的科学问题
就是比如说我是不是有一种可能
就随便举个例子
就是有没有可能是
我生成
我自己生成数据的这个链条当中
用到了别的模型作为辅助
或者说我自己模型生成的答案
用别的模型作为它的评价者
这个其实是一个我觉得商业上来说
比较灰色的地带
但是从技术上来说其实很有意思
因为你想其实从某种意义上来说
可能中国的实验室
成为了做Multi Agent（多智能体）训练的先驱
哦
而且是真正的Multi Agent
因为它如果从不同家的模型里
用这种比较聪明的方案
把他们融汇到一个训练系统里的话
每家模型它可能是是分布很不一样的
它的语言的分布是很不一样的
这个是真正的Multi Agent
它可能比起
比如说我用了好几个Gemini一块做
是一个技术上更有趣的事
所以说我觉得对我来说聪明的蒸
我不知道这个商业上
最后会不会变成一个很明确错
或者很明确对的事儿
但技术上其实很有意思
你这两种蒸分别说的是谁
能不能后期把名字哔掉
（可以）哈哈哈哈哈
我首先没有在中国的lab（实验室）干过
所以我不知道确切的是谁
但是我的感觉就是
XXX
应该是硬蒸了啊
然后XXX可能曾经硬蒸过
但是后来可能慢慢也在努力
向软蒸的方向转化
我觉得比较明显
可能蒸馏的比较少的是字节
我觉得字节是我感觉到这个模型
还是比较有特点
嗯 特点体现在哪里啊
比如说这个模型
你说它有多聪明呢
我觉得
豆包是肯定没有Gemini和Claude聪明的
但是豆包首先
比如说豆包的语音生成非常非常强
哎 这个很难吗
在技术上 确实豆包是做的最好的
因为我发现我生活上的问题
我只想问豆包
因为它很快
但其他模型
为什么不优化这个产品功能呢
我觉得还是跟它的用户群体有关系
在美国
我觉得大家的这个想法更专注于
怎么能够提高工作效率
你生活没有一些困惑吗
我生活中有
首先
我个人
确实是一个生活上比较无聊的人
所以我生活中没有很多有趣的困惑
可以去问豆包
我生活中更多的困惑
都是技术上的困惑
问Gemini这种聪明的模型就是最好的
哈哈哈哈哈
对
我没有什么半夜去打豆包
情感电台的需求
不只是情感就是很多
比如说你做饭
嗯
你可能会遇到一个什么问题
你可能及时需要一个 需要有人告诉你
但是你又没有这样的人
嗯 那些
我觉得可能更多是数据上的问题
然后可能更多的只说美国的公司
现在主要的主要的优先级是在智能
或者工作效率上
未来有天
会不会变成这些日常的事情
我觉得是有可能的
事实情况是
你如果去问这种日常话题
其实
你能发现Gemini
每一代到另外一代
会做的也越来越好
嗯
其实我身边很多朋友
包括我自己以前也是
就是我以前在Anthropic的时候
可能写code会去问Claude
但我可能日常查个什么东西
我就会去问Gemini 对
你用过豆包没有
我其实只用过一两次
我发现你们都不怎么用
嗯 首先
是不是鄙视链
（有智力的鄙视链）哈哈哈没有没有不至于不至于
就是我觉得首先就是
就跟在中国的人试图用美国的模型
会有一些复杂的事儿一样
哦
我在美国用中国的模型
其实也是挺复杂的
第二呢就是确实也没这个动机
尤其我觉得我可能生活中
工作是工作
休闲的时候就是找不一样的工作
所以对我来说
我的最好伙伴就是Claude和Gemini
但是可能对别人来说并不是这样
所以可能也只是我个人的问题
我自己用豆包的那一两次
是因为有人给我展示豆包手机
哈哈哈哈哈对
那你怎么看豆包手机
我觉得是一个很好的想法
我个人觉得效果上来说
其实做的也不错
当然我不知道的是
技术上来说它的优化做的有多好
就是说它
我觉得它实现一些任务的实施
从效果上来说是没什么问题
但我不知道它会有多大的消耗
如果这个消耗非常非常大
那可能是一个技术上需要解决的问题 嗯
因为你并不希望什么
让你的模型去给你订了一张高铁票
结果花的钱比高铁票还贵
这个肯定是一个不可以接受的事
对 所以说
可能技术上来说
我个人不清楚它有多成熟
然后我觉得产品上来说
对大家来说还是一个挺
不能说惊讶吧
但是让大家觉得挺兴奋的事吧
然后我觉得
可能苹果以前也想干这样的事
只是苹果可能自家的模型一直不太行
苹果好像不是很在意它的AI战略
现在 我觉得呢
苹果一定是在意AI战略的
因为曾经Siri手机助手
是苹果发布会里
一个非常非常重要的闪光点
但是自己的模型没赶上趟
现在可能要通过和Gemini合作
来试图做这样事
至于现在它是不是重视
首先我也不知道
你要让我猜我肯定觉得是重视
但你要让我解释
它为什么从外界来看没那么重视
我的唯一猜测就是
如果你外界来看就显得很重视
还做不成
那就显得很蠢
啊
挽尊
啊对哈哈哈（我不在意）
那我们说一下豆包的模型啊
你刚才说豆包模型比较有特色
你能具体一点
一个是它的语音做得很好
这是第一点
我觉得语音做的很好
是我能感觉到最有特色的事
就是我觉得语音这个效果可能是
客气地说可能是全世界最好的之一
不客气地说
我觉得就是全世界最好的
嗯 这很难吗
嗯
我自己没做到那个地步过
所以我也不知道是不是难
但是我觉得可能是一个很费功夫的事
不管从数据上还是各种优化上来说
它是个产品的事还是模型上的事
它一定会是模型的事
它有可能也包含一些产品的部分
但一定是一个模型的事啊
对 然后
我觉得这是一方面
然后另一方面
另一方面我自己感受就不多了
因为我其实用的机会没那么多
那可能就是更多的是来自于
就是亲朋好友的反馈
也就是说
哎 这个豆包这个模型就是fun to talk
就是聊起来很有趣
哈哈对
但我觉得那个
更多的是一些主观的反馈
我觉得它的那个一个是语音
然后一个是它
生成的很快也是一个很重要的
因为我很多模型
它都在给你展示思维链
但是我就说你们生活上的琐事
我不想看它的思维链
对 这个事我觉得技术上并不难
只是可能
大家目前还没有花更多时间
在这个上面
然后事实情况是
如果你去尝试Gemini 3.1和Gemini 3的话
你会发现
Gemini 3.1
在完成同样一个问题的时候
已经会比以前快很多
然后废话少很多了
所以说我觉得这个不是一个
嗯 在我看来不是一个技术上的难点
它更多只是什么时候去重视
去做这个事
我觉得可能就是现在
现在美国的这几家
还都处于
在努力把智能的上限往前不断推进
而字节呢
当然它也肯定是在推进上限的
但是我觉得
它可能就是在用户的优化上
也做的很不错
最近还有一个话题
就是中国的机器人很火
在春晚上
我不知道你对这个有没有什么观察
看过一些表演
也在亚马逊上搜过一些价格
确实很惊讶它居然这么便宜
哈哈哈买了吗
没买哈哈哈
我买了也没什么用
但是确实我以前会
我不知道我以前脑海里觉得这种人形机器人
然后
当然就是软件层面其实没什么
但主要是硬件
我觉得硬件上做的这么成熟
可能怎么也得是个什么
大几百万美金啊这样的
但是好像我去看了一下
价格比这要便宜很多
我觉得这还是体现出
中国在硬件这个产业链上
还是很有优势的
但是我
并不知道它
作为一个
它作为一个机器人
硬件来说
我觉得确实是非常非常强
然后从软件上来说
没太看明白
我觉得机器人的模型
也是一个目前非共识比较大的事情
对
怎么说
就是说它
我觉得机器人的模型可能更多的处于
嗯feature engineering（特征工程）的时代
就是你让你有一个给定的环境
给定的场景
你去优化这个场景
大家是知道怎么做的
嗯但是做RL嘛
做强化学习
构建合适的虚拟环境
还是虚拟的
这种
这种数据
然后你去做训练
是可以提高的
但是它没有很强的泛化性
我觉得这个是
就是有没有泛化性
其实是很多AI方向它的一个分水岭
就是一个确定的场景
一个很单一的场景
能不能做好这个事
不是最近这几年才解决的
十几年前就能干
就是像语言也是语言
在这个基于Transformer这种类似架构
之前的时代里
并不是说完全做不了
对吧那时候
你也可以训练很强的模型去做翻译
嗯
你可以训练一个很强的模型
去做语义分析
但是你不能做的事儿是
我可以水平的提高所有的能力
嗯
这个我觉得是一个分水岭
然后我觉得language model（语言模型）在
在Transformer和GPT之后
跨入了那样一个阶段
跨过了一个
就是可以水平的提高所有能力
然后你可能在一个点上的训练
它会把这样能力抽象的
泛化到所有相关的事情上
但是机器人我觉得没到那个阶段
更多的还是在那个阶段之前
就是我有一个单一的场景
单一的的事情
然后我能够为这个事情去做优化
所以你怎么看
硅谷的这些机器人团队啊
还包括Gemini内部也有很多机器人的人
嗯
你会怎么看
那个方向有点这
这算什么
这是你们的子方向
还是你们的平行方向
还是什么
我觉得
过去是一个挺平行的方向
但是现在机器人
我觉得大家也在尝试
就是能不能利用语言模型
作为一个基底模型
然后在那个上面去训练这种类似
比如像VLA（视觉-语言-动作模型）啊
特别是多模态模型
对对对然后嗯
所以现在来说
就是变成了和语言模型这个
这条线比较相关的一条线
嗯
然后我觉得我个人的感觉是
他们未来会变得很重要
但是目前还没有找到自己的路
但是他们做的事真的很有意思
我非常推荐大家去看看
机器人的实验室
比做语言模型的实验室要有趣的多
做语言模型的实验室
感觉就是正常的办公室
但机器人他们是真的
就是会有人去操控这个机器人
采集各种数据
然后去看这个机器人在什么
在货架里去取各种各样的货品之类
干这样的事情
觉得是很有意思的一件事
你去的是哪家
啊我去
我在Gemini自己的实验室
不是Gemini
就是那个Google DeepMind的自己的实验室
去看过
然后还有那个Dyna
我也去看过
他们是个叠衣服的机器人
对他们就是可能场景更单一一点
就是我叠衣服
是一个机器人 可能做一些别的事情
就比如说倒水啊之类的
这样对
你直观感觉
机器人进展相当于大语言模型的哪一年
还没有到GPT-1的时刻对不对
一定没到
我觉得一定是没到的对
嗯
就是相当于大家还没有
没有想明白怎么去scale up
我觉得对我来说
不管机器人还是多模态生成
都没到这个点
那接下来进入今天的主题
我们还是对你非常的感兴趣
然后聊一聊
你是怎么从一个学物理的人
进入AI的世界的
嗯
你从小在哪儿长大
你是怎么长大的
我
我出生在宁夏
然后一个很小很小的城市
叫那个大武口
看就是你这困惑的表情
已经说明了这个城市有多小
嗯
这个城市过去的存在是因为一个煤矿
也是因为石炭井
一个煤矿
然后有了这样一个城市
对所以我在那出生
但是我
小学的时候跟我父母一块去了上海
然后所以
我小学的后半段和初中高中是在上海
然后我上本科就去了北京
就是刚才所说的那些
就是上本科在北京
然后博士在美国
对
你从小就成绩很好是吗
你是物理竞赛保送
然后在清华和斯坦福读的是理论物理
对我不是物理竞赛保送的
哈哈哈哈
我觉得我小时候挺菜的
啊首先
我读的初中和小学都是无名之辈
哈哈哈
我觉得我
我当时读的初中好像就是竞赛
不是一个你该考虑的事儿
就处于这样一种这么一个初中里
那个叫上南中学东校
又是一个大家听了很困惑
一脸一头雾水的学校
好 既然都说到这那小学是哪个小学啊
小学叫啥来着(德州二村小学)
我的context management（上下文管理）能力太强了
我已经不记得叫什么了其实
哈哈哈嗯嗯对
然后对
就是就是那个初中
就是嗯
一个班里面一个小的环境
还是有一些想要好好干事的同学的
但是总体来说
那个初中我觉得是比较躺平的状态
对 然后
我觉得就是可能学习还可以（还可以是什么）
还可以就是当时的状态就是
上海高中有所谓的
那时候有所谓的四校
有什么上海中学
然后华二
交大和复旦的附属中学
对
然后当时的状态就是能上这四个学校
但上不了这个四个学校里最好的班
但是我当时特别想搞竞赛
因为以前都没搞过竞赛
你初中开始搞竞赛
我初中没搞
哦 我初中没搞过竞赛
没搞过竞赛为什么想搞竞赛
因为没搞过
所以想搞
怎么植入的概念（哈哈哈哈我这个人）
我这个人的个性就是
总是爱干一些自己不太会的事
哈哈哈哈哈对
然后当时没搞过竞赛
但是知道有这么回事
所以觉得义务教育
不是义务教育就是上大学之前得干一把
所以但是呢
那个成绩也没好到那个份上
所以
去四校 就是最好那四个学校
是进不了搞竞赛那个班的
我当时就发现有一个稍微差点的学校
那个学校就是格致中学啊
稍微差一点的学校
但是那个学校有一个竞赛班
然后我感觉这个竞赛班
本来按照现在的话说就是underdog
哈哈哈哈哈
厉害
用当时的话说我感觉就是光脚的不怕穿鞋的
哈哈哈哈哈
我觉得 嗯
可以一搞
所以就 其实当时 那个那时候就是
那时候
上海还有这个所谓的退休生的制度
就是你可以在考中考之前
就去和某个学校签约
然后你就提前向预定那个学校的名额
然后就直接去他们那
然后就很自然去了
然后去搞了竞赛高中
所以你其实是在上海四校的普通班里面
和这个格致中学的竞赛班里面
义无反顾的
选了格致中学的竞赛班
当然我也不能
我不能说我做选择的时候
这个上最好的四个高中
是那么板上钉钉的事
虽然后来的分确实够了
那时候还没中考呢
对对但是当时就觉得
就算能上
我也应该去一个underdog的地方赌一把
为什么
因为想干这个事啊
你想干竞赛的目的是什么
我觉得当时最主要的事是想体验
我觉得没干过
一定要找机会干一下
为什么一定要干一下这个
第一就是觉得确实难吧
啊就是确实比
就有一种对难的兴奋感
对
就是确实
至少当时
没搞的时候
大家给我的印象就是
感觉这个事比你不搞竞赛
学的那些东西要有挑战性的多了
嗯
感觉干这个事的人确实强
不干你也就只是这个平庸石头里
最光滑的那一个
所以我当时觉得要干
所以就去干了
当然干了之后也实际上带来一些好处
就我后来回想起来
如果当时没去搞竞赛
可能就进不了清华了
哦你是有加分还是什么
当时其实那个
竞赛的保送生制度已经比较锐减了
就只有进国家集训队才能保送
我那高中
反正我觉得
我当时没进国家集训队这个水平的
所以就别说了
但是呢就是我在考高三竞赛之前
阴差阳错的去清华参加了一个夏令营
然后阴差阳错的在夏令营的最后一天
听说了他们在
搞自主招生
但是主要是面向北京的学生
我就疯狂给招生办的老师发短信
说我要跟他们一块儿考
他答应啦
然后他就答应了我们去考
你们还是你
就答应了
我
和我们这高中一块去的那几个人去考
就上海去那个夏令营的那几个高中同学去考
哦你有什么理由说服他给他发短信
我已经忘了这个短信具体怎么说了
但这个短信大概说的意思就是
你给北京的同学考
为什么不给上海的考
哦理直气壮是吧
你当时觉得他们在开后门是吗
我也不是觉得他们开后门
就是觉得人家有这个机会
凭什么不给我们
大家都在一条线上竞争嘛
就你们当时是同学啊
然后所以就发了这个信息
然后还人家就真让我们去考了
几个人
我记不太清了
可能有上海
去那个考场里可能有七八个人的样子
是你发那个短信
可能
可能别的高中也有别的同学发
但我们高中是我发的
哦就是
都是上海高中
去北京参加那个夏令营的同学
参加夏令营的同学
然后就让我们考
然后就签了
这么好说话
对 所以我从那件事得到的
人生最重要的道理就是
胆子要大
哈哈
你不争取是永远得不到的
争取了也有可能得不到
但不争取就绝对得不到
你当时发那短信的时候忐忑吗
你当时还高中哎
我已经不记得了
当时觉得
自己这是个很大胆的事儿吗
没有我当时满脑子想的都是
现在就得争取
再不争取明天就争取不到了哈哈
就是
我在听说的那天就赶紧去疯狂发短信
疯狂发给谁发
发给招生办的
那清华招生办的老师
就发给一个人还是多个人
不记得了应该是一个老师
对他很快回了吗
嗯嗯嗯我觉得清华的
就say yes了
我不知道他们自己有没有讨论了
但是反正最后是说了是同意
然后就一起考试了
对
所以我所以我
为什么我感觉
我一直对清华还还是挺有感情的
就我感
觉这个学校是是愿意给大家提供机会
给大家提供平等机会
你那考试考得怎么样
嗯我当时出来的时候觉得考挺崩的
因为有半道题没做出来
但是我后来发现别人没做出来更多
就果然就招了
哈哈哈哈哈对对
你那一波上海同学进了几个
啊好像两个
自主招生
是减分还是什么
是降到一本线
降到一本线
哦
然后你高考考的好吗
后来高考果然没考到清华的分
但是就是除了清北之外的学校都能上
哦
所以为什么
网上都写你是保送的
我觉得就是大家
没在那几年上过学的人很难
很难理解清楚那几年到底发生了什么
因为在我的两届之前
还是拿了省一等奖就能保送的
拿了省一等奖就能保送了
你们那时候呢
我们那时候就是拿了省一等奖
进了省队
然后再代表省队去考国家的比赛
然后进了国家集训队才能保送
我是进了省队去考了国家比赛
但我没考进国家集训队
对
所以说我那届我是没有保送生名额
哦
你搞竞赛搞得好吗
我觉得挺菜的
就是
难道不是没有干到最好就是很菜吗
然后我显然没有干到最好啊
所以就是很菜
你家里人对你搞竞赛这个事情
是什么态度啊
我觉得我爸妈最好的一点就是
他们不太管我
他们可能曾经也试图管过我
后来发现管不住
哦怎么管不住
就是我也不听他们的
哦
我觉得可能大多数中国家庭都是
孩子和父母商量已经算是很好的了
我一般都是通知
哈哈 通知了啥
通知 哦 我去自主招生了
嗯 然后
包括中高考填志愿也是
我爸妈甚至可能都没见过我志愿单
哦他们比较佛是吗
他们我觉得就是
当你没有办法理解别人在干什么
的时候 别指手画脚就是最好的
我觉得我爸妈这个道理懂的很好
嗯哈哈哈哈哈
那你比较叛逆是吗
我觉得我是
比较
我个性是
我很care我想做的事
如果这件事是我自己想明白了要去做
你就别拦我
然后我也一定会尽最大努力做到最好
但如果这个事我不想干
逼我干也没用 我也不会干 对
你的胜负欲强吗
挺强的
对但我觉得我更多的是在跟自己
跟自己较劲吧
不太愿意和别人较劲
哦 对
当然就是如果
就是
正好是我觉得这事儿很重要
你也觉得这事儿很重要
那我肯定是要干得比你好呵呵呵
好那你到了清华就更神了
去学的量子物理 为啥呀
对我当时做那个凝聚态理论然后
为什么选这个专业
阴差阳错
现在回过头来说
当然能
能编造出一些听起来很合理的理由
但是摸着良心回到当初
我觉得就是阴差阳错
就是当时我们在机科班
然后机科班有一个非常好的传统
就是首先机科班它虽然在物理系
但不限制学生干什么
机科班实际上2/3的学生都不会做物理
啊
然后对于
你为什么会进这个班
呃
当时清华的物理系全都是机科班
现在可能不是了
反正当时是
然后它另外一个好的传统是
它鼓励学生在在实践中学习
所以它鼓励学生
尽早的去进到科研的实验室里去
然后去在科研中学习
然后我当时想很想做理论然后
是因为觉得这个难吗
感觉 就是你对难有一种着迷
可能也是一种病
我之后可以再讲讲这个
这个病带来的不良后果是什么
哈哈哈
对然后然后那个对
然后我想搞理论
然后当然机科班
或者我们叫学堂班
有一个更小一点班
然后那个
老师就推荐说哎
高等研究院是个很好的地方
清华高等研究院
就是杨振宁先生创立的那个研究院
是个很好的地方
然后我就去那找老师
然后正好有一个
那时候还很年轻的老师叫
叫汪忠是我本科的老师
嗯 那时候他也没几个学生
然后我俩就聊
我当然啥也不懂
但他还挺耐心
还给我了
给了我一些这个paper让我去读
然后读我就跟他讨论
后来又发现凝态理论
尤其当时做的那个方案
就是跟拓扑绝缘体
然后这些比较相关的方向
其实
是一个很适合本科生上手的方向
就是它需要的背景知识不太多
它只需要你可能懂
最最基本的就是你得会量子力学
会统计力学
会固体物理
也就是其实非常非常容易学的
基础知识
但是它可能很考验
你对这些知识理解的深度
所以对于本科生来说
其实是一个特别好的方向
就是你能够很快的上手
去做一些实际的项目
然后我们就一块做了一些工作
其中有可能
在开放量子体系里面的那个工作
现在看来还是一个挺重要的工作
对然后
从某种意义上来说
我觉得现在回头来看
做那个工作
做那段时间的科研
其实和现在做AI特别特别像
就它更多的是你有一个想法
你有一个理解
然后你可以在那个阶段
就是你可以做一个数值的实验
去验证你这个想法和理解是不是对的
你发现AI其实也这样
AI也是你有一个想法
你有一个理解
你去设计一些实验
验证你的理解是不是对的
然后你设计一些模型上的
训练的这个pipeline（流水线）
来把你的想法实施出来
对所以说其实这两个是很像对
能不能讲讲你这个非厄米系统的研究
啊可以讲
我尽量说人话
但是也有可能实际上说了鬼话
所以要是不想听的人可以跳过
哈哈哈哈哈
滑一下进度条
到时候可以在进度条上设置两个戳
对然后对
非厄米系统是这样就说
量子力学一个最基本的假设是
一个孤立系统
它的演化被幺正演化所描述
幺正演化是个鬼话
对不起
幺正演化的意思就是
它是一个线性的过程
然后这个线性过程
它可以被一个算子
叫做哈密顿量来描述
啊哈密顿量从某种意义上来说
它有有点像这个体系的能量
但不完全是
就是有点类似于
所以
它决定了这个体系随着时间的演化
然后如果是一个
孤立系统的话
这个哈密顿量会是一个厄米的矩阵
厄米的矩阵就是你转置一下
然后做一下共轭
它和原来是一样的
但是呢真实的系统
绝大多数都不是孤立系统
比如说你
我作为人
肯定要和外界有信息交互
有物质的交互
材料也是一样
就是你一块材料放在那
除非你抽特别特别真空的
你总得和衬底有交互
你得和外界环境有交换
所以真实体系
绝大多数时候都不是孤立系统
然后孤立系统
它就不会被一个幺正的过程去描述
然后它所对应的哈密顿量
也不会是一个厄米的
哈密顿量
就是这个非厄米这个词的来源
它本质上是为了研究开放量子系统
就和外界有交换的量子系统
它的行为
然后当时发现一个很困惑的事是
我们一开始是试图研究
这个开放量子系统里的一些拓扑现象
然后就发现
手算出来的这个理论的结果
和数值死活也对不上啊然后
更确切地说
就是手算这个结果
是假设了这个体系
是一个周期的边界条件
比如它在一个环上
或者在一个这个轮胎的表面上
然后数值的话就会
因为就和实际的情况比较类似嘛
它就会算一个开放边界的
比如说一个方块这个材料上的行为
就发现这两个结果死活也对不上
然后就试图理解这个事
后来就发现
大家过去用来描述厄米系统的
一个一个基本的的范式
就是所谓的这个布洛赫波
就假设物体的本征态都是
一些波的线性组合
这个
正弦余弦波啊这种
这种波的线性组合
这个假设
其实在非厄米系统里面会
break down（发生故障）就是会变成错的
事实情况就是
后来我们就发现
在非厄米系统里
其实它的能量的本征态
都会
有可能会聚集到这个体系的一边边去
对然后我们就系统地建立了这套
这套描述的方法
然后就是建立一套体系
去描述一个开放边界的非厄米系统
它的本征态该怎么去描述
进而描述它的一些随时间演化
和一些动力学
所以
这个是当时这份这个工作
然后后来就有很多
因为因为它其实是一个
一个范式上的更新嘛
所以后来就有很多
很多follow up的工作
但是后来其实我换方向了
所以就没有太在这个方向继续做了
你为什么不沿着它做
很难抓住一次范式的变化是不是
很难抓住一次范式的变化
是的是的
这就是人性的弱点
就是我感觉
我总爱挑战一些自己不会的事
哈哈哈尤其当时
就
我不知道我当时的感觉是在那个方向
可能那个工作从再过几年回头来看
就会是这个方向最重要的工作
后面你再去做一些工作
可能确实会让你更有名
获得更多的引用
写更多好的期刊的文章
找到一个好的教职
但是感觉作为一个科学生涯来说
就没那么令人激动了
所以我当时就想换个东西做
换一个自己不太会的
东西做对
然后
所以就读博士的时候就换了一个方向
去做高能理论
高能理论对
高能理论物理对
所以你本科和博士也是不一样
也是不一样的
还不是从物理跳到AI
其实你本科和博士看起来都是物理
其实方向也已经发生了很大变化
对是两个几乎没有任何联系的方向
哦 你这个很神奇
还包括你选竞赛
去那个格致中学也很神奇
对
这是你的什么人性
我觉得就是
说难听了就是爱折磨自己
哈哈哈说好听了是挑战自己
哈哈哈
嗯被折磨开心吗
我觉得如果为了被折磨而被折磨
那这个人就是有心理疾病
但是
如果一个人是为了学习更多的东西
丰富自己的经历和能力而被折磨
我觉得是值得的
你本科那个老师
汪忠老师也是个underdog是吧
算吗
不算哈哈哈
人家做的挺好的
怎么可以这样说他哈哈哈（在那个时候）
刚说他很年轻嘛
没没没他很年轻
但是他
我对他的印象一直都是
他是一个很sharp的人
就是很能看问题
试图理解问题
理解很清楚的人
确实可能不像很多老师那样是
就是很有名气
在社会上或者很光彩夺目
至少那时候不是
现在已经很有名气了
那时候还没有那么有名气
但是我觉得从能力上来说
我觉得他是很强的
对 然后其实他一开始是
他读博士时候是和那个守成老师
张守成老师学习
所以说
能被守成老师挑中的人
基本都不会太差
嗯
他对于你博士换方向说过什么吗
没说过什么
我觉得他是一个
他是一个不爱干涉别人的人
哈哈哈哈哈
我不知道他内心是怎么想的
但是我觉得
他是一个不爱干涉别人的人
诶 量子物理
整个是一个什么样的世界观啊
它跟 嗯
我觉得
我觉得最大的区别就是我觉得嗯
有很多
和经典物理有很多很多不一样的地方
但是我觉得
它们两个是一个对应的概念是吧
经典物理和量子物理
他俩是一个在不同能量和时间
或者空间尺度下的理论
就说 本质上我们这个世界都是量子的
当然就我们现在
也不知道比更小的尺度上会是什么
对吧就
更小的尺度上
有很多不一样的想法
比如说弦论是一个想法
然后看看其他想法
量子引力也是个想法之类的
对但那些都没有办法验证
被验证的
小尺度上的有效理论就是量子物理
最小最小的尺寸
被实验上能够验证的
最小尺寸的有效理论就是量子
当然这里面包括量子力学和量子场论
然后经典物理是
当你所看的这个空间尺度和
比较较大的时候
这个量子物理
会慢慢慢慢退化成经典物理
其实它更多的是在不同尺度下的
有不同的有效理论
对这个这个事儿
其实在物理上是一个很深刻的想法
就是所谓的重整化群
重整化群说的事
就是说
在描述一个体系的理论
在不同的能量尺度下
可能看起来是完全不一样
对然后哪怕他们可能从根源上来说
都是一个大一统理论
当然在现在
没有什么真正的大一统理论了
如果存在的话
他们哪怕在根源上是同一个根
但他们在不同尺度上
可能看起来也是完全不一样
所以经典物理和
量子物理
更多是两个不同尺度下的描述
讲到量子物理
有几个词好像是相关的
比如说蝴蝶效应
比如说量子纠缠
你能不能讲讲这些
我觉得这个可能是大家能听得懂的
然后我也不懂物理
大家不要骂我
我也不懂量子物理
对我觉得
量子纠缠
确实是一个大家比较耳熟能详的
量子物理比较独特的事情
然后呢就是很简单啊
就是说我有两个粒子
比如它属于一个纠缠态
然后我可能它们实际上相隔很远
但实际上
我可能对其中一个做一些测量
或者微扰
它也会影响到另外一个的状态
这个是真实存在的
这是真实存在的对
什么样的会有量子纠缠
什么样的两个物体有很多
有很多
就是有很多
实际的情况
就是实际上
当你足够看得足够足够细
足够足够微观的时候
绝大多数的粒子可能都处于纠缠态
但是实际上来说
你可以
比如说制造一个自旋和另外一个自旋
你先把它俩靠在一块儿
然后把它俩坍缩到一个纠缠态上
然后你可以把其中一个拉得很远
后来就成了一个纠缠
就是一个距离很远的纠缠态
然后甚至好像我记得几年以前
还有人专门去做
把一个细菌和一个什么什么东西
制备在一个量子纠缠态里
什么叫制备
在一个量子纠缠态里
这个是可以人为操作的
这是一个可以人为操作的事
为什么 怎么操作
一般来说
就是通过一些
一些测量和和演化算符的作用
能够把它
制备到这个状态上
但是这里面难的
其实是实验上怎么实现
这个过程
就是你可以想象
就是说你做一些量子测量
和一些和一些所谓的量子门的操作
其实是
比较难的
就又回到刚才那个问题
就是每一个体系它其实都不是孤立的
你可能这两个自旋
你觉得哎
我这样子制备一下
不就到纠缠态了吗
那我再把它拉开不就完了
但是实际的问题是
这两个粒子其实活在我们这个世界里
会不断有别的粒子
撞它一下
或者外面的热量还扰动它一下
它一下就状态就没了
所以难的是
怎么具体实验上去实施这个过程
对然后
纠缠的另外一个粒子可能更耳熟能详
我其实应该提那个例子
就是薛定谔的猫
薛定谔的猫
那就是一个更耳熟能详的例子
就说它的状态其实是叠加了
某一个放射源发出粒子
和猫死了
这是一个状态
另外状态是放射源没有发射粒子
猫活着 这两个东西的叠加状态
其实比如说
你去测量一下那个放射源
发现放射源放出粒子了
你就知道猫死了
不管这猫和这个放射源离多远
对所以这是纠缠
但是蝴蝶效应是一个
是一个另外的事
然后蝴蝶效应这个事
嗯蝴蝶效应就是耳熟能详的部分
其实反而是经典物理
就是大家经典物理听到的
蝴蝶效应就是那个著名例子
就是什么可能南美洲一
个蝴蝶扑棱一下翅膀
半个月之后
什么北美洲刮了个台风
但是它从更数学的表述来说
它就是说在时间
起始的时候
你如果做一个很少的很小的扰动
然后你去测量这个扰动产生的影响
在未来有多大
你会发现
这个扰动的变化是指数级变大的
对这是它数学上
对经典蝴蝶效应的一个描述
但是之前大家比较费解的一件事就是
这个事情在量子体系里怎么可能存在
因为量子体系刚刚说了就孤立
孤立量子体系是一个幺正演化
它是一个很线性的过程
所以说从某种意义上来说
就是你如果一个状态
就是一个矢量和另外一个矢量
开始的时候夹角不太大
那经过一些演化之后
这个夹角应该不会变
然后所以总会存在
这种就是初始状态变得离得
差别很小
在未来啪变得就是指数级变大
好像在量子力学上看是哎
不太可能实现的事
但刚刚又说了
其实我们的世界是在微观是量子
然后在宏观就变成经典了
但它俩是一脉相承的
怎么可能这有那没有啊
这是大家试图理解的事
那当然
这个后来大家就有一些更好的理解
就是说其实
你讨论这个量子里面的洪荒效应的时候
不应该讨论两个态之间的这个
这个变化
而是应该讨论一些
就是所谓的local observable（局域可观测量）
就是局域的观测量的变化
那个其实是对应了经典物理里的
你的看到的那些变化
那你读了4年的量子物理
以后 你当时在想什么
你觉得物理对你的帮助是什么
在你大四要毕业的时候
我觉得本科期间读物理最大的帮助
就是第一
想问题要想清楚
就是读书不在于读的多
而在于读的深
你读的多 不代表你能够发现新的东西
但如果你对一件事
有和别人不一样的见解
那个才是对这个社会来说
更有价值的事
这一件事
然后另外一件事就是别太相信理论
别太相信纯理论
因为
得出了这个结论啊
因为当时那个事发现的主要原因
还是因为能做数值
就一开始是因为数值和理论对不上
才仔细的研究那个问题
然后发现了这个事
那你博士为什么去读了高能物理
也是一个理论啊
这也就回到了刚才这个话题
就是总爱挑战很难的事
有时候也是会带来一些不好的结果的
什么不好的结果
比如我就感觉
我觉得我这个博士就是对我自己来说
学到很多东西
成长很大
但是于这个世界来说
没有产生什么贡献
哈哈就高能理论这个方向
就是足够难
非常非常难
然后嗯
但它不好的事情在于
它其实不是特别可以验证
没有什么客观的评价标准
因为
高能理论已经发展到了就是
实验完全追不上的这个阶段了
实验完全追不上你在理论讨论的那些
不管是能量尺度
还是这种微观的尺度
对
它是怎么进步的呀
它的进步依赖于什么呀
如果不是实验
一个进步的来源
是来自于数学上的自洽性
嗯 就比如说
你提出一个框架来
来描述这些事情
那你能和现有的已经
被验证的更低能标下的理论相自洽
就比如说
你研究弦论
那可能自然大家问题就是
弦论能不能在低能情况下
回到量子场论
进而回到经典物理
那这个自洽性是一个判定方法
我觉得这个是很合理的
就是很科学的一件事
当然也有一些不科学的因素
就是当这个领域完全没有实验
没有客观标准的时候
肯定不会只有一个框架出现
肯定不会只有一个自洽的框架出现
这个时候谁做的好
谁做的不好
其实就依赖于
领域内一些老登的主观判断
你是被谁伤害了是吗
我也没有被谁伤害
只是我在那个领域待时间越长
就越觉得这件事蠢 就是
人这一辈子也没多长
为什么要把自己的时间
浪费在伺候老登身上
对
所以感觉是花了5年学了很多知识
买了一个大教训
这个教训是
这个大教训就是要（要做实验）
哎就是要做
有比较客观评价标准的事
嗯或者从另一个角度来说
或者从另一个角度来说
就是
要做对这个世界能够产生影响的事
所以其实你本科还是比较顺利的对吧
在量子物理这个研究领域
很快
你很快就有了非常好的学术成果
而且是范式级的变化
但是你很快觉得没有吸引力了
所以
你想在博士去挑战一个更难的事情
对
然后在博士期间其实是比较落寞的
至少从结果来说是这样的
哈哈哈
外界看不出来
外界看都是非常光鲜的履历
博士在Stanford
对我觉得
我觉得从实际的科研产出来说
我觉得
没有人会说我博士期间的文章不好
但是摸着良心说
对这个世界有多大的影响
我觉得几乎没有
没有影响 几乎为零
对 所以对我自己来说
我自己很不满意的啊
但是我觉得确实也没有不满意到说
我会担心有人说我在混日子
确实也没在混日子
就是你还是能达到所有的外界标准的
对
这是怎么做到的呢
就是这个还真的是
很多事情冷暖自知对吧
对是的
我觉得达到外界的标准
或者达到一个小的圈子的评价标准
是像训练模型一样
就是一旦有了这么一个小的圈子
你知道他们的评价标准之后
做得好是很容易的
就是其实你哪怕不认可这个标准
你是可以达到的
嗯嗯
但是你还是知道你是不认可的
因为有时候你哪怕不认可
你达到了
我也可以蒙蔽自己就继续往前走
但我后来就发现我蒙蔽不了自己
骗不了自己
嗯
对
是哪一年发现的
我觉得可能从
博士最后的两年吧
就会有这样的感觉
但是那时候确实也没有想好
没有想清楚如果不做这个该去做什么
那可能就花一些时间去了
去了解一些不一样的方向
比如说
一开始我可能更多的是去
是去了解是量子计算
或者量子信息这样的方向
然后拿了postdoc offer
就是博后的offer之后
感觉这个事更紧急了
因为在学校里的时候
你还可以一个学生的心态
离开学校之后就是自己的career（事业）
你得给自己找一条路
那当时就是觉得
可能量子计算和AI是两条
我觉得给年轻人
给小登机会比较多的
所以你博士后的方向是啥
博后没有方向
博后其实就是理论物理这个方向
博后是一个很独立的职位
就是你自己想干啥干啥
对它更多的是
从某种意义上说有点像搞慈善
啊啊
谁搞慈善啊
嘿嘿就是有一些可能
不管是在意科研的国家组织
还是个人组织
它会给学
校捐一笔钱
或者给学校批一笔钱啊
学校用这笔钱来招一些博士后
再一个系里面就做研究
然后把自己的研究
广泛的告诉系里的别的人
觉得它更多的是一种一种社会氛围的
这种
这种工作
对然后
所以其实没什么限制
就是你其实想干什么就干什么
但是我其实也没做
多长时间的博后
我实际可能到伯克利待了两三个月
但官方来说就只待了两个星期
官方来说是什么意思
就是我
我其实在入职之前已经去那了
因为我反正人就在湾区嘛
我在入职之前就去了
但是我入职之后
其实只待了两个星期就辞职了
这两个星期发生了什么
这两星期啥也没发生
我本来都不准备入职的
但是伯克利人就是太好
就是嗯
没事 就是等事情定了再说
能来多久就得来多久
哦你告诉他们你其实在跟Anthropic谈
对
我告诉他们
其实我觉得我可能会去做AI了
我要不就别入职了
嗯
但是伯克利不是
不止伯克利
我觉得就是湾区
这两个学校的老师都人很好
就他很照顾你
他就觉得你还没有完全谈定
那还是先把现在的工作先拿着
你觉得物理对你后来做AI
有什么帮助吗
我觉得硬实力上其实没什么帮助
就是纯工具性的技能上来说
其实从物理到AI的的转化
是非常非常少的
但是我觉得可能非要问的话
我觉得可能主要的
主要的
不
不能说能力吧
就是性格吧
可能是
可能做物理人会更想刨根问底
更想理解一个事儿
然后更想做事很系统
因为我们习惯了这种很系统性的
不管是做实验的方式
还是做理论的方式
所以我觉得这个可能是
一个比较好的地方
但是
我也不觉得这个事是做物理人独特的
就是
为什么做计算机的人没有这个特性呢
我觉得我认识很多做计算机的人
也有这个特性
那很多学化学的人也有这个特性
学生物也有这个特性
所以我也不觉得它是做物理独特的
对但事实上就是可能比较有趣
就是这个领域里面确实有很多
尤其就是语言模型这种比较
就large scale（大规模）的这种AI
确实有很多物理出身的人
然后做的很成功
对尤其Anthropic这个公司
很多人在描述这一代AI的时候
都会说是黑盒
你能用科学的角度
来理解一下这个黑盒吗
就人工智能的运作原理
我觉得
这世界上所有东西都是黑盒
就是哪怕像物理这种
大家觉得很理解的东西
其实也并不是真的有一个
从它微观的行为
一路演化到了宏观体现的这种理解
像不管是刚才说的量子力学
还是量子场论
其实都是描述那个能标下的行为
本质上这个系统还是一个黑盒
你还是不知道它最微观的地方是
什么样的动力学
AI也是一样
就是黑盒不黑盒
其实都是一个相对的事
我们确实对语言模型没有理解到
神经科学手术刀级别
就不是说我理解这个行为
能理解到
说这个行为是由于哪一个neuron
哪一个人工神经元的哪一个激发
产生的这个行为
不会有这个
没有到这个层面理解
除非就是在一些很稀疏
很小的这个网络里面
就是像Anthropic
有这个所谓的Interpretability
就可解释性团队
他们可能会做一些类似的工作
但是在实际能够使用的语言模型里
都没有达到这样的理解
但是也不代表我完全没有理解
比如说Scaling Law
它就是一个描述了那个尺度下模型
随着模型大小和数据是怎么在perplexity
就是这个指标下变得越来越好
嗯所以你说是完全没有理解吗
那如果说
Scaling Law
不算是理解的一个小部分的话
那是不是我们也说
我们其实对这个世界也完全不理解
这个世界也是一个完全黑盒
所以Scaling Law是一种科学规律
它是一种经验规律
经验规律
对
但是呢
经验规律和科学规律
它之间的界限是很模糊的
比如说
我们回头去看这种热力学的
各种不一样的定律
第一定律第二定律
什么克拉伯龙方程
乱七八糟这些东西
在当年被发现的时候
也都是经验规律
但是只是说后来
哎随着时间的发展
我们慢慢知道了它的微观机制
那它可能变成了一个科学规律
对我觉得可能像Scaling Law
或者类似的这样的东西
它目前肯定还是很惊艳
但是未来当技术它变得比较固定
然后大家开始越来越多的理解它
微观的过程的时候
会不会变成一个科学规律
如果这个定义是存在的话
我觉得是有可能的
能不能用科学的表达来解释一下
所谓的智能涌现
首先这个话就不太科学
所以自然也没有办法用科学的话
来表达一个不科学的事
智能涌现吗
就是我觉得智能涌现
对我来说它更多的是一种主观的感觉
而不是一种客观现象
就是当很多人说智能涌现的时候
他脑子里想的可能是以前的语言
模型只能做某一个方向的事儿
比如只能翻译
只能做分析
只能做什么
但现在模型好像
哎可以做所有的事儿
但是这个事儿
again我觉得像是
对我来说
它更多的是一个技术上的涌现
而不是一个行为上的涌现
说是我们通过研究
发现了
该怎么去做这种大规模的的训练
然后能够水平的提升所有能力
我觉得这个是一个更本质的事儿
至于智能涌现这个事儿
其实我觉得嗯
每个人可能心里的定义都不太一样
对
你的定义是
对我来说就是没定义
呵呵呵对我来说
这个唯一质的区别就是
有没有发生一个技术上的改变
使得我们可以做scale up
可以水平的提升所有的能力
这个对我来说
是一个良好定义的事
你最后是在量子计算和AI之间
选择了AI
这个是怎么发生的变化
对我觉得还是花了
一些时间去了解
两个方向的瓶颈在哪
我觉得好处是他们都给年轻人机会
好处是
都有机会
但是量子计算对你来说
好像是离你的主线更近一些
在那个时候对不对
哎这就是为什么要去了解一下细节
因为了解细节之后发现不是的
是反过来的
因为量子力学
哦不是量子力学
就是量子计算
我觉得它现在的主要瓶颈
其实在实验上
并不是你怎么去设计那些算法
或者设计那些算子
更多的是你怎么在实验上实现它
那个事反而是我不擅长
反而是和我过去很多
我有兴趣的事
其实是比较不相关的
然后反而跟我相关的事儿是更多
像AI 就刚才说的就是
更多的是你有一个想法
然后你可以用一些数值去验证
这个数值在AI里面
可能就是训练一个模型或者怎么样
对然后这个反而和做物理很像啊
它甚至是
就是为什么
我之前一直爱把这个
和18世纪的这个物理学
做比较
就是它对更像那个时代的物理就
是那个时代就理论和实验不分家
没有什么理论物理学家
实验物理学家
你就是搞物理
就是搞物理的
你自己可以做实验
然后也可以做理论推测
我觉得AI就有点像那个时代
所以其实
从理论物理跨越到实验物理的距离
比你直接跨到AI要远
要远嗯
其实要远
而且从兴趣上来说也更远
你不喜欢实验物理
（我觉得）你不喜欢做实验
我觉得嗯
确实不是我的兴趣所在
嗯虽然我不自己不愿意做
但是我确实很有兴趣
知道别人的实验做的怎么样
哈哈哈哈哈
AI不用做实验吗
用 但是它是更多是像数值
对它不太像
那个就是你实验室去搭一个光学平台
然后什么
你还要
我觉得实验真的是一个
就可能因为是我不懂
我没有达到那个境界
所以我有些事在我看来挺玄妙的
比如说
其实大家都知道这个光学平台怎么搭
但有的人就能给你搭出来
有的人就是耗了6年都没搭出来
这个是动手能力
我就是没搞明白呀
哈哈哈哈哈
我有时候觉得
这事有点玄妙
哦
嗯所以还是数值
数值是要清晰很多
对对对对我来说
做数值实验
或者像AI
就是训练模型啊
然后研究各种不一样的技巧
来看某某些细节
这件事对我来说反而是嗯是
我能想明白它为什么要这么干
嗯 但是在搭台子这个事上
我就是一头雾水
你做过是吧
我当然就是
大家可能都做过基本的
就读物理的人肯定都
做过基本的实验培训
但是更多的就是有很多做实验的朋友
然后不管去看他们的实验室
然后看他们怎么做实验的
还是跟他们聊这些怎么设计实验
我就感觉很多事我其实不太能够理解
但是他们确实有的人就是做的好
有的人做的就是不好
所以你说现在从事AI研究
像17世纪从事热力学研究
其实在表达
虽然大家没有办法很清晰的
从科学上去解释和理解这个事情
但是并不会阻止它发展
对就是它更像是在
为什么
比较那个时代热力
学就是那个时代
大家其实不理解什么是热的微观理论
就大家不知道 热是什么东西
就像现在不能理解
对就像现在
大家不能理解
这个language model（语言模型）里面
哪一个矩阵元是在干什么
其实大家也不理解
但是不妨碍你有一些好的经验定律
比如热力学的各种定律
和现在的各种Scaling Law啊
所以说
从这个角度来说是
就从这个
从这个方向的角度来说
是
这个层面上来说
它是类似
然后从研究人员的角度来说
就是刚才说的另外一个问题
就是它理论和实验其实不太分家
那你是怎么去面试Anthropic的
你这个Anthropic的历程是怎么展开的
我觉得其实主要还是
因为有前同事在Anthropic
哈哈对
前同事
就是Anthropic
其实有很多做
做物理出身
尤其是做理论物理出身的人
为什么呀
他们从人的选择上
为什么会选择这一波人
我觉得
当然就是很多
嗯
很多人可能会找一些原因说哎
做物理人擅长这个或者擅长那个
但是就我个人的视角来看
我觉得主要的原因还是connection
就是联系
就是因为Anthropic的创始团队里面
其实有
当时有三四个比较比较技术的人
然后其中有两个
现在还很在技术一线
领导的人
他们俩都是做物理出身的
然后他们可能招的一些人
也是做物理出身的
所以就这样一直延续下来
但其实到现在这个阶段
就在我之后
其实也几乎没怎么再招
完全没有AI背景的人了啊 对
所以说也是一个
我觉得也是一个时代的产物
对然后
我反正是当时我决定去做AI了
所以我就试图去联系一些地方
然后
你只找了
Anthropic吗
没有我还找了OpenAI和GDM
就Google DeepMind
但Google DeepMind
因为它那时候速度太慢了
哈哈哈所以就没
就没有
最后没有出现在考虑的范围内
但是
速度太慢了
是指他们面试的速度慢哦
但是后来
显然后来
Gemini这个事就获得了长足的提升
后来动手就非常快
哈哈对
然后Anthropic
就是反正
OpenAI呢
OpenAI也联系了
但是OpenAI
可能没有找到特别合适的事和人
然后Anthropic是因为我当时联系了
后来就是
我的第一任
那个manager
我第一任经理
然后他以前也是做这个理论物理的
然后他当时就说
我们在尝试做强化学习
尝试做这种大大规模强化学习
有很多科学问题要去理解
那个时候24年
八九月的时候
那个时候
其实
强化学习还没有像现在这么成熟
那时候
大多数人其实都不太知道怎么做
因为o1其实还没发布呢
那时候o1只是对对对对
就是
只是
大家都知道有
但是大家都还没看到结果
但Anthropic当时其实不知道怎么做的
当时是大体上知道
但是有很多细节需要仔细去研究
所以他就跟我说哎
有这么一个事
你要不要来面试一下
然后我觉得哎
可能是一个好的机会
你当时怎么认知强化学习啊
没认知哈哈哈
你大概知道pre-train
post-train对对对
我大概知道这个流程
但我其实不太知道具体的这种
工业级别的语言模型是怎么训练的
嗯
只能知道就是像学术界是怎么训练的
对然后
所以其实现在谈那时候的认知
在我现在看来就是没有认知
对然后嗯
更多的还是
我当时觉得这个事是一个不确定的事
然后是一个好的机会
所以我就去干了
嗯
当然也有些面试的准备和面试过程 对
怎么准备的
聊啥
我当时
跟谁面
Anthropic后来我的一些同事当时面的
然后
面试题也不太难
反正哈哈哈对
但是对我来说
我当时也不知道怎么准备
我就去把我能找到的那些课
自己能学的学了一遍
然后能做的作业做了一遍
然后自己手搓了一套
就是那个Andrej Karpathy
他有一个著名的那个项目叫
好像叫nanoGPT还是叫什么
反正就是他有一个
可以在一个Google这个Colab Notebook里面
就能训练一个很小的GPT模型
然后我就手搓了一下那个
然后就去面了
对
然后很快拿到了offer
然后就对
然后就拿到offer
然后
你第一个方向就是大规模的强化学习
也当时其实是有两个组来
两个组的manager啊
来跟我聊
一个是做evaluation
就是模型评测
然后另外一个是做强化学习
我是选择了强化学习
你当时选择强化学习
是因为它更加的不明朗对
嗯嗯然后那时候
其实Anthropic也不像现在是一个大公司了
那时候公司其实也很小
多少人
我去的时候
我们的那个大的team才只有10个人左右
或者10个人
或者11个人
大team叫什么
叫Horizon
对然后
那个时候那个大team
也就是这个大team的平行team
有什么
那个大team其实后来几乎就是
强化学习的方方面面都在这个team了
对但那时候
那他的整个大组
就是一个强化学习
整个大组
首先这个创业公司
你也很难说这个组的目标是什么
因为
他可能曾经也有过很多不一样的目标
但只是那个阶段
可能主要的目标是做强化学习
对 然后
当然底下也有做更数据的组
更做环境和infra和基础设施的组
也有更做这种research和算法的组
然后我去的那个组
是比较偏research和算法的组
嗯 那时候Anthropic多少人
啊 那个时候可能
七八百的样子吧总共
但是整个的公司
七八百对
你一进去对这家公司印象是什么呢
我觉得
我觉得我对Anthropic的印象
其实还是挺
挺consistent（一致）的
就是我觉得进去之后
这家公司的印象就是执行力非常强
就是它
它其实是一个比较top down（自上而下）的公司
对然后
所以很多事情决定了之后
就会全力去做
然后
公司其实员工之间的的氛围也很好
就大家都
不会藏着掖着
然后尤其刚去时候很小嘛
所以就是
大家也都认识
所以就氛围很好
然后
我觉得
如果是做
只是做语言模型相关的事的话
其实现在回头来看
那是一个非常非常好的学习机会
就是你能够接触到这个模型
训练的方方面面
然后都能找到对应的人去问
那个时候的Anthropic已经有了
现在我们都知道
他那个非常坚定的bet了吗
有的有的
这个bet来自于哪里
为什么会有这个bet
我不知道它完全的来源在哪
我自己能看到的一个显然的来源
就是前一代模型
Claude 3放了之后
Twitter上那时候可能还没叫x呢
Twitter上有很多人在讨论说
那个Claude 3好像写code比GPT-4强啊
那个年代
GPT-4还是一个和大家gap很大的模型
所以能有一件重要的事比GPT-4强
就很厉害了
所以是试出来的
我觉得至少是其中一个原因
就是是很快的对这个市场做了反馈
对 这也是我觉得这公司很强的一点
就是它execution执行力非常非常强
一旦给它一个信号
让它觉得是很reasonable（合理的）
这公司该做的事
那就会铺上去
它没有那些大组织那种冗余
为什么它的coding定会比GPT-4要好
不能说哈哈哈
哦是有原因的
是有原因
是有原因的 对
但是个随机的原因
不是我这么选择
所以有了这个结果的原因
是一个纯技术原因
但是
确实 我不
我不能确定一开始是随机试着的
还是故意选择的
你要让我猜
我肯定会觉得是随机试着的
哦
纯技术的原因
是有某个人做了某个事情
是确实有某一个团队做了某个事情
是自上而下的
还是自下而上的
我觉得最开始可能是自下而上的
但是后来就变成了一个自上而下的事
就是要快速捕捉到一些市场
对就内部和市场的信号
对对
我觉得这个是
要赶快要扑上去
对对
我觉得这Anthropic是非常非常强的一点
它非常非常的reactive
反应非常快
它执行力来自于哪里
来自于Dario这个人
来自于他的某种特质
我感觉就是
嗯Anthropic
作为一个公司来说
它能够实行这种
就是比较top down的机制
是一个很独特的事
为什么呀
因为
实行top down其实有有一个很难的点
就是你做技术的决策人
必须也得是公司本身的决策人
嗯
首先就是你技术上得能服众
那下面的研究员才会
你才能够就是
信服下面的研究员去做这个事
另一方面就是你得是公司的决策人
你得能为这个公司负这个责任
那Anthropic有这个条件
就是说它的技术上的leader的领导人
其实是公司的cofounder
是你指的是谁
不是Dario Amodei
就是像 Jared Kaplan
和Sam McCandlish啊
然后像他们俩就是公司cofounder
嗯他们自己做这个决定
那是人家的公司
所以他有权利做这个top down的事
那Dario作为CEO
他会say yes和no吗
我不知道他们决策层的讨论里面
哈哈哈OK
Dario起到了什么样的作用
我只能说
就技术leader是有决定权的
对我当时的工作来说
我接触的最多的就是Jared
可是这对于其他模型公司很难吗
很难 比如说OpenAI就干不了
‌Ilya‌在的时
候难道不行吗
‌Ilya‌在的时候有可能可以
但是‌Ilya‌后来一方面
嗯我也不知道因为什么原因
他好像就是失去了这个做决策的能力
然后他就走了
所以就
其他公司呢
其他公司我觉得都比较难
就是Gemini也比较难
但是我觉得Gemini就是另外一套打法
不太一样
就是说嗯
我觉得就是大公司和startup
它打法本来就不一样
因为startup重要的是make bet
就是我得我得赌一件事
我如果想要赌
就意味着有风险
所以就意味着
我能够去很快的做一些决策
然后很强力的推进一些决策
嗯 那可能在这种情况下
top down我觉得是一个很有优势的事
所以我觉得Anthropic从组织上来说
是比OpenAI更有优势
但是作为大公司来说
它可能就是另外一套想法
因为大公司的想法可能是
我不仅能尽量减少做赌的成分
而是我能在方方面面都有储备
然后任何一个事成了
我都能跟上
然后如果有事我自己做成了
我可能还能领先
这可能大公司的心态
所以说在Gemini
Google是一个很传统的
就很bottom up的组织
就是公司层面
可能有一些比较良好定义的框架
来看你的工作是好是坏
来引导你做一些公司需要的事儿
但是本质上
还是你自己来决定自己做什么
所以你觉得Anthropic能make bets（指对coding下很重的赌注）
是因为它的独特的文化
组织和文化 对
这个听起来
其实应该是其他公司也能做的
但是却非常奇怪的发现
其他公司很难做
而Anthropic可以做到
对我觉得还是需要技术的
或者公司的leader有公信力吧
这个其实挺难的我觉得
你说的还不是CEO有公信力
是技术的1号位有公信力
对对我来说
我觉得技术的1号位有公信力很重要
但是与此同时
CEO可能没有成为一个阻力
对
这个难吗
啊这个我觉得就得看你这个
这个cofounding的这个team
有没有足够的互相信任
嗯这个也很关键
我觉得Anthropic这点也是
在startup里很强的
就是他cofounding team
没有一个人离开公司
他们 如果你看他们过去
那是一群真正一起打过仗的人
就过去
他们源自于 他们都是以前OpenAI的员工
嗯对
然后
他们甚至好多人都是
就是在一系列关键的文章上的
合著者 因为你像
Scaling Law这个paper
是Jared Kaplan然后Sam
然后当然还有Dario
然后还有一些
可能Tom Brown也在吧
我不太记得Tom Brown在不在
然后GPT-3的paper就是Tom Brown在
然后Benjamin Mann在
然后Jared Kaplan和Sam也都在
Dario也都在
所以他们是一块趴过战壕的人
我觉得互相之间的信任还是很关键
嗯 有很多公司可能就是干着干着
连这个小集体都团结不住了
那你怎么能指望
这个大公司能团结住呢
你在说OpenAI是吧
嗯 哈哈哈
你加入Anthropic
公司正在做的最重要
的项目是什么
你参与到那个大项目里面了吗
对
就当时做就是为了做大
能做大尺度的强化学习
然后能够用它来提高coding的能力
这个就是当时最重要的事
嗯然后我们当时做这个
这个组
当时的研究重心就是这个事
这也是这个组为什么后来就慢慢变大
然后变得越来越重要的原因
然后
最终带来的结果就是
就是大家一块train了这个3.7
Claude 3.7这个模型
哎你说内部叫有一个3.6
这个是
不是内部叫
就是外界的
Claude 3.5其实有两个版本
一个可能是6月的版本
另外一个10月版本然后呢
你也可以看出啊
Anthropic这个公司
曾经也是没啥产品能力的
居然管两个模型叫一个名字
哈哈哈哈哈
所以后来外面人为了区分
管那个3.5后面那个版本叫3.6
所以Anthropic跟随着外面的这个习惯
就叫3.6了
管这个再新的模型叫做了3.7啊
所以就是
你去看实际的这个公司的产品时间线
其实是3.5 3.5new 3.7
怎么会有一个3.5new
这个是怎么想的
你这哈哈
我只能说
那个时候的Anthropic
可能真的是没有什么产品上的想法
所以你第一个项目是3.7还是3.5
3.7 3.7
还是3.5new
3.5new
其实我
没参与 几乎没参与
但是3.5new
就已经看到了coding的迹象
是吗 你刚才刚开始的时候
3.5new的时候
已经看出
Anthropic的模型
在agentic coding会比别的模型强了
这个是为什么
不能说哈哈哈哈哈
所以你进去的时候
刚刚好就是
他们知道了这件事情
就是管理层也知道了这个迹象
对然后他们要make bets的时候
你这个运气很好啊我觉得
我觉得 对
我觉得我进去的时候是
大家肯定已经看到了
这个事儿能做成且重要
但是不太清楚怎么去把它做成
然后我去的时候
是跟大家一起去研究怎么把它做成
对 所以方法是大尺度的强化学习
对 这是从大的角度来说是
但是当然就是
有很多技术细节是需要去研究的
这里面有什么knowhow啊
哈哈哈有好多NDA（保密协议）的内容呢
哈哈哈
NDA会写的这么详细的吗
其实原则上来说
原则上来说
员工是不能在在职期间和离职之后
透露任何跟公司内部相关的信息的
当然实际上来说就是
大家可能心里都有一个度
就是说
如果这个技术没有公开的话
肯定是不会公开去谈的
但是我觉得虽然我不能公开去谈
但是
我觉得
把简单的事儿做的比谁都干净
是最关键的
什么叫干净啊
你刚才也用过这个词
对就是就是
我觉得有很多花里胡哨的技巧
比如说做强化学习
最简单的algorithm（算法）就是Policy Gradient（策略梯度）
但是不代表这是唯一的algorithm
它还有别的算法
比如说各种复杂的
这种搜索算法之类的东西
但是
是不是这些复杂性是必须的
然后这些复杂性可能给你带来了
一些efficiency
也就是效率上的提升
但它可能给你带来一些
比如说
基建infra上的困难
那你怎么去trade off（权衡）这些事
这些事其实做研究需要去理解的
就是怎么去balance这种不同的因素
然后选择最好的那条
最稳定的那条路
对然后我觉得很多的knowhow
其实都是在这些
这些细节
怎么去处理这方方面面细节对
那那个时候怎么来描述coding很重要呢
我觉得
它认为是大语言模型的一个分支
一个重要的分支
还是什么呢
我觉得每个人可能想法不一样
对我来说
它重要的原因有二
一个原因就是
一个原因呢
是Anthropic一直在讲的事
就是说coding本身
也是做语言模型研究的一部分
如果你能够把coding做得很好
那可能会让你的研究效率
有翻倍的提升
嗯就是形成一个研究上的飞轮了
这是一方面原因
对我来说
另一方面原因
是因为coding其实是模型
使用工具和环境交互的
一个很好的抽象
首先这个抽象刚刚已经说过
就是这个抽象的好处在哪
比如说这个回归信号清晰
然后数据充分
然后
其实你是很难在别的场景下
找到
能同时有这两个特质的使用工具场景
所以对我来说这是一个好抽象
在这里面做的一些研究
可能是对更通用的
那些使用工具和环境交互的能力的
一些有用的
有用的lesson有用的课
那时候Cursor是什么状态啊
那时候Cursor还是一个
纯产品公司
我觉得从某种意义上来说
好像在我去Anthropic
这个之前的那段时间里
Claude和Cursor都属于比较underdog的状态
然后somehow在3.5new就是3.6
外界的3.6这一代的时候
首先是这个模型能力上去了
然后Cursor又发现
这个模型
真的能够做这种Agentic coding的工具了
它就是一个壳
对但是这个壳包着这个模型
一下子让公众体会到了
不是公众
公众是指就是软件工程那个圈子
当时 嗯
体会到了
哎这事好像是真的是效率工具了
所以后来就是这个一下就起来了
所以那时候
Anthropic就意识到
Cursor是未来的竞争对手
那就不知道了
该问Dario哈哈哈哈哈好
3.7是怎么做出来的
这个是一个分水岭
对于Anthropic来说
是一个分水岭式的模型
我觉得对于Anthropic的后训练来说
是一个分水岭
就是在3.7之前
后训练都是处于一个比较
嗯
比较小规模
然后
可能就是修修补补
模型的这种一个状态
大家不重视后训练是吗
也不是不重视
就是一开始大家
其实很长时间
大家都没有搞明白
后训练该怎么scale up
哦 但是在那个阶段
不管是OpenAI还是Anthropic
还是包括像中国的DeepSeek对
他意识到了这个事该怎么去scale up
然后该怎么scale up
就是你得找到
合适的环境
这个环境它的回馈信号足够的清晰
这个环境本身也是一个很强的数据源
然后
在这个上面其实
能让这个训练非常稳定
这事就能做成
对我记得那个时候
其实大家都不知道
OpenAI的保密项目是什么
就知道它叫草莓
叫Strawberry
然后嗯
大家觉得会带来一个新的范式
新的范式就是后训练强化学习
但是更多的就不知道了
对其实
我觉得我去Anthropic的时候
大家已经比较清楚
这个事该大概该怎么做
就是大概的这个方向是怎么做
然后
当然后来就是后来
随着我对这个领域知道越来越多之后
我就发现
其实那个时刻
其实OpenAI做的方式
和Anthropic其实还是差别挺大的
怎么说啊
就具体这种算法
和使用数据的方式
其实是不太一样的
虽然都叫后训练和强化学习
嗯 虽然都叫这个
但是当然就是我觉得那些不是不是
本质区别 就是大的方向来说
它们是同一个
就是找了一些
找一些这种很回归
信号非常清楚
非常客观
然后数据本身又比较干净
然后对模型来说是可学习的
然后在上面做稳定的强化学习训练
大的方向来说都是这个方向
但具体实现其实是差别比较大
但后来事实也证明
就是具体实现
其实每家方向都不一样
但是都能做成
嗯 而且当时OpenAI的目标也不是coding
当时我了解到的叙事是说
预训练作为第一个范式
已经金矿快挖完了
所以我们现在开启第二个金矿
就是后训练和强化学习
然后来让Scaling Law继续对
我觉得很长时间
OpenAI都是这个这个想法
我不知道他们现在想法有没有变
我觉得对我来说
我的想法经历过摇摆
在3.7那个时代
我其实觉得我
我当时也抱着这个预训练已经快
party is over（狂欢结束了）
这种感觉
然后就在你要入职的时候是吧
就我刚入职
然后当时在做这种3.7相关的
这种实验的时候
我当时也曾经抱过这个想法
但是后来随着了解越来越深入
我就觉得发现
其实还有做的空间的啊
然后嗯
预训练Scaling Law这个事
它也不是告诉你要一直变大啊
它其实本质上是一个很系统的框架
能够告诉你做什么样的事是更有效的
对 嗯
然后
所以后来就发现
其实还有很多做事
事实情况是
后来Anthropic
和Gemini的预训练
也一直在不断的进展
OpenAI自己卡了很久
哈哈哈它现在又重视预训练了吗
它应该已经重视预训练挺久了
就是最近可能刚刚有点进展
所以预训练和后训练作为两个范式
都没有达到它的平台期
我觉得都没有
但是你说要去预测到了多少
这个做不到
对就我觉得
我觉得到达平台期有
有两种
两种可能性
一种可能性是技术本身到达了
就是你明明还有想让模型要干的事
但是这俩技术就死活教不会了
另一种可能性是
你想干的事到平台期了
我觉得现在就是后者啊
就是我们现在知道了哦
有一个Chatbot
你可以教它干这个
然后又有一个coding
后面就不知道了
对就不知道该教点它啥好
就是说
这模型还是一个非常聪明的小孩
对你其实可以教它很多东西
对但是我们人类作为老师
现在还不知道下一个东西该教什么
对对
或者说该怎么去合理的教它
用现在的这些范式
说到3.7 还有什knowhow
这是几个月做出来的
这个最后林林总总
从开始训练到发布
可能花了四五个月的样子吧 对
就是从你刚进去
就是从开始大家
为了这个事做研究
那可能花了两三个月
然后后来开始训练到训练结束
中间磕磕绊绊
很多事情要处理啊
然后有很多新的基础设施
其实基础设施真的是很重要
很花时间
然后又可能花了可能两个月这样子
你在其中
做的重要的工作是什么
我觉得我也没什么重要的
哈哈哈哈
我觉得
我对我个人的贡献
我觉得我个人
对任何一个模型的贡献
我的陈述
都是
我觉得我自己对那个事没那么重要
我觉得我更多的是我很幸运
有机会
在那个时候加入了一个重要的项目
做了一些事
嗯 因为从某种意义上来说
我觉得AI在现在最近这几年
这个事本身是一个不可阻挡的事
它不在于你这个人去干或者不干
你不干也有别人一样能干出来的啊
所以我觉得在这个时代
其实所有给个人贴金的事
其实都有点炒作
的嫌疑
但是确实我觉得对我来说
我是很幸运
能在那个阶段加入一个重要的事
然后 哎学习了一些知识
好的那你在幸运的在那个阶段
在Anthropic
这家公司的
大尺度强化学习的这个团队里
做了什么
我觉得3.7那个时候可能主要做的还是
就是在做这个Agentic coding这件事儿
这件事儿怎么把它scale up
或者怎么去准备
就是怎么去制备
各种各样的环境和data
包括算法上会遇到什么样的问题
当时主要的研究都在这部分
这里面有什么tips吗
现在来看没啥特别有用的tips了哈哈哈
我觉得
说到说技术的tips
其实这个事儿
是一个大家很一方面很愿意听
公司又不让你说
但实际又没啥用的事儿
为什么
因为很多算法设计其实并不独立
独立于算法
它是非常强的
依赖于你的基础设施
举个简单例子就是
有些公司
它可能就大家经常讨论一个问题
就是说在强化学习时候
这个sample（采样）就是给你产生这些
这些trace（轨迹）
这些token(词元)的那个机器和trainer(训练器)
用来实际训练这个模型
然后改变这模型权重的这个机器
这两个机器可能会有不一样
但是不一样
有一些原因是因为数值上的不一样
有些原因是因为
使用了这种异步的训练架构
所以说它自然就是
从根本上来说就不一样
那你不同公司可能这个不一样
程度是不一样
所以你算法的设计也会不一样
有些公司它可能这两个difference
这两个区别非常非常大
那你算法可能最大的部分就是在于
怎么控制这个
然后怎么让这个训练稳定
对于训练的这个实际的效果啊之类的
权重就会稍微小一点
但有可能有的公司
它的基础设施建设就特别特别好
这两个差别没那么大
那你可能就可以花更多精力
在这个训练的效果上
所以说很多这种小的tips是
其实是没有什么用的
就很多knowhow其实是没什么用的
我是因为我确实也发现了
就是很多
别的lab就不是
在这三家lab里的人可能很想知道
哎 Anthropic怎么做这个
或者Gemini怎么做那个
但其实我有时候不愿意回答
一个主要原因
是因为我觉得本质上
我回答这个问题也是在误导他
就是现代的AI训练是一个大的系统
你其实要了解
这个系统的方方面面
才能有一个全局的认识
什么事是因为什么而变得有用了
而不是说这个事本身有用
从3.7到4.5又发生什么呢
这个预训练和后训练都有对
然后嗯
当然就是一个
就是scale up上做的更多了
然后data
不管是data还是训练的
这个算力都更大的尺度了
但是我觉得从范式上来说就没有
没有特别特别大的改变
到你离开Anthropic时候他已经多少人了
接近2000人了吧
扩了一倍多
啊嗯
所以你在Anthropic时期
刚好是他就最剧烈转变的一个时期
啊我可能就是踩在了
它还是个小公司的尾巴啊
其实我觉得进去之后过了可能三
四个月这个公司就已经开始
哎就人一下就变多了
文化有变化吗
还是经历一些比较混沌的阶段吧
然后
尤其可能就是在我离开的那段
快离开那段时间
我觉得文化上还是经历了一些
一些混沌
因为从外面啊来了一些人
可能跟本来的文化有些冲突
哦之前的文化是
我觉得之前就是
比较简单
对就很简单
就是它
更像是一个小作坊
大家都是朋友
然后大家都知道对方在干嘛
然后
也没有人特别特别会
就是做
过多的这种个人宣传啊还是怎么
就是做一些没有用的事
也没有人做没有用的事
大家都是有很多事要处理
然后公司那时候
可能紧迫感也更强一些吧
然后后来可能就觉得这样
人多了嘛
这样的文化肯定会受到一些冲击
带来了什么风气啊
我觉得
确实有一些人我个人不是很喜欢
当然不代表他们真的不好
就说我个人不是很喜欢
就是可能我不太喜欢
在这个领域里面说很多话的人
就是那个我觉得idea is cheap
想法是便宜的
很多想法
其实很显然所有人都知道
难的是怎么把实现
怎么把它变成一个一个小的
可实现的步骤
把它做出来
我觉得我不太喜欢那些
一天中很多时间花在
在Slack就是Slack
是美国用的一个办公的这种软件
然后在Slack上花很多时间
在那讲一些大道理
我觉得就是
没啥用哈哈哈
你后来为什么突然离职了
你是完成了什么阶段性的工作吗当时
酝酿了多久
当时我觉得可能酝酿了
一两个月
一个多月吧
一个月多一点
好快对对
我觉得一个方面是
嗯就是是
我其实不是太特别认同Dario反华这个事
啊我觉得他作为一个公司的CEO来说
对他个人来说
他做什么样的观点我觉得都无所谓
但是作为一个公司的CEO来说
我觉得
把这个观点推到这么极端的地步
是一个非常情绪化的体现
对然后这是一个比较小的原因
但大的方面
有很多公司
像刚才说的
公司的文化上有些冲击啊
然后包括我自己
可能也想去学些不一样的事情
就说Anthropic
它毕竟非常的专注
然后你可能做
如果你很想做和语言
模型相关的方方面面
然后
做这种使用工具啊这种Agentic
然后coding这种事
那在Anthropic其实很好
能学到很多东西
但是Anthropic有很多不做的事
比如说Anthropic完全没有人做
这种多模态生成
你想学没地儿学
然后Anthropic可能也没有花太多的精力
在这种更底层的
工程的
基础设施上
对
所以可能想要学习更多的东西
也是我当时离开的一个动力
反华占百分之多少比例
因为Dario的个人原因
我在公开场
合说40%
但是这个数字反正就是听听就好
这个数字就是告诉你
它不是主要原因
但它确实是一个很大的原因
就没有控股
不是个控股原因
对不是个控股原因
但是是一个majority holder（多数持股人）的原因
你这个选择也很神奇
因为大多数人
在一个它还是一个underdog的时候
加入会更有感情
会愿意陪公司走更长时间
但你反而跳去了Google
因为很多研究员一进Google
他会觉得Google给的scope（管理范围）不够
嗯
所以他会反而想跳去像xAI
或者Anthropic这样的更小一点的组织
你这个行动好像也是反的
对我觉得
其实取决于你自己想要的是什么
如果你很想要的是我有一个很明确的
像你说的很明确的scope
然后这个事
和我的最后产品的模型息息相关
我一定要把我其中的一个想法
送到这个模型里去
那可能Google是一个很差的地方
因为毕竟有那么多的研究员
有那么多已经成熟的组织
做这件事情是
有很复杂的这个过程
但是我觉得Gemini很
如果你想要的是你有研究的自由
有探索的自由
然后想去能从更广泛的人类学习
我觉得这个世界上
可能找不到第二个比Gemini更强的地方
所以
所以就是
我觉得
本质上还是取决你要自己想要什么
但是我觉得很多人离职
不管从哪离职
换到另外一家之后
可能会觉得不开心的主要原因
是因为没想明白自己想要什
么 比如说你要是到了Google
但是跟我说
你刚开始想的是我有要有研究自由
然后更多的动机是学习
然后你去了之后
发现还是想要有产品impact（影响力）
那你可能就会很难受哈哈
你不追求impact吗
你在你也个说这个
现在这个AI是一个非常大的系统
然后是一个
很大量的人协作的一个东西
你在里面追求什么
我觉得分阶段
就是我觉得
在Anthropic
经历了太多
这个和产品息息相关的事之后
我可能也想给自己换个脑子
去学习一些不一样的东西
但是你说有没有哪一天
我可能又换回这个脑子
又想去产生一些产品的影响力
也是有可能的
产品影响力怎么量化
这个内部都很清晰
是吗
不好量化
就是我觉得
因为发论文的时候还是有一作
这种作者主导作者
现在呢
嗯其实没有办法量化
实际情况就是没有办法量化
这也是为什么我觉得在这个时代
其实谈每一个人个体的影响
是一个很很虚无缥缈的事情
觉得本质上还是这个组织做了
这样一件事
或者这个世界需要这样
所以产生产品impact是个主观感受
在模型侧至少是这样的
在模型侧至少是这样
对然后
当然实际上你可以
我觉得可以
细节谈的是说你自己做过哪些事情
具体的技术的贡献
然后在技术上产生的效果
这个是可以客观的去谈论的
但是比较主观的事是
你说
这个效果在最后的产品里占了多大
的比重 这个没有人能说清楚哦
3.7上你能描述一下吗
你做的什么样的技术性的工作
对模型是产生影响
主要还是跟Agentic coding
的环境有关的工作
然后也有一些算法上
算法上主要是怎么让这个训练变得更
更稳定
说实话就是
但是我觉得算法上肯定是有一些提升
但是也没有达到特别理想的效果
说实话啊
比之前的算法肯定是要好的
对
但是那个我觉得也不是我个人的贡献
我觉得也是大家集体的贡献哈哈
对 我每次问你
你都会说这是集体的贡献
嗯不是一个个人英雄主义的时代
对我觉得个人英雄主义时代
对于language model来说
可能过去了
什么时候是啊
就是在Transformer的那个时刻
对就是在那个技术
还没到scale up那个点之前
那找到了那个技术的人
可能是一个英雄
或者找到那个技术的一个小团体
可能是个英雄
找到那个技术之后
可能很长一段时间
从模型侧来说都是
我觉得更多的是集体主义
就是这个集体能不能一起工作
能不能为了一个目标
一起花自己的时间
花自己的精力
这个是最最重要的事
而不是每一个个人
提供了什么样的东西
说集体主义的原因
是因为其实能力是来自于AI 是吗
是因为我觉得AI这个方向本质上是简单
就是
我觉得没有哪个
除了可能跳变那一下
那个idea可能是
得有一些很深刻的洞见
在之后的那个过程中
很多想法其实是非常trivial（微不足道的）
就是非常愚蠢的
就是谁都能想
谁都能干
只是你运气好
撞着这个机会去干了而已
包括你在描述Anthropic
做coding好像它也是某种随机性
但是你要抓住它
对对 但是就是我觉得做coding
可能还比做模型
侧的这些技术上的东西
可能还更稍微有点公司英雄主义
就是说你能不能足够快的赌这件事
嗯那确实还是一个Anthropic很强
但如果今天没有Anthropic做
可能别的公司也做了
我觉得是的 就是一个必然的事
所以它都是AI在涌现能力
只是看你能不能抓住那个能力
不管是公司还是个体
对对
我觉得就是在这个可用的语言模型
大尺度的语言模型出现之前
那个时候很多事情是一个非必然
就是有没有一个人能够发明一个东西
一个语言模型能够大尺度的做训练
以及GPT这个范式
能不能被发现出来
那是有很多不确定性
嗯但是你说比如
那个时候你说如果没有Google Brain
那可能Transformer就不会被发现
可能要过很多很多年
才会另外一个有钱又有人的组织发现
那可能就是一个很大的影响
但是进入那个阶段之后
尤其到现在已经反过来
就是你任何一个组织想要停止AI进展
是做不到的
Anthropic有
就是Anthropic很担心AI安全
那Anthropic有没有这个能力阻止AI发展
它没有
你阻止发展 你停止发展
别人会发展
你的话语权还会变小
对 其实现在是
其实更多是这种这样一种状态
世界在推着我们前进
而不是我们在推着这个世界前进
感觉未来我们会更加难以阻止AI
哈哈我觉得已经阻止不了
就是我觉得
试图去阻止AI里的一件事发生
可能本身就不是一种正确的想法
这也是就刚才聊到
因为刚才聊到Anthropic嘛
就说Anthropic其中一个很重要的动因
是所谓AI安全
我觉得它在AI安全这件事上
就是它创立的时候动因
对啊
现在跟它有什么关系
现在的关系比较复杂就是说
一个自然的
问题是大家可能会问
一个做AI安全的公司
为什么现在开始训前沿模型了
Anthropic的的解释是说
我首先得拥有一个最前沿的模型
我才有话语权来推进我的AI安全
所以说它其实一直以来的想法是说
我要做这个世界上最好的模型
大家不得不听我的
来推进我的安全政策
但其实从我个人角度来说
我觉得这个想法是非常幼稚
就这个事现在看来
它是不会发现不会发生的
更有可能发生
就是大家都有很好的前沿模型
而你没有办法阻止任何事发生
可能对于这个事来说
现在更多关注的更多该想的事是
如果你真的想要避免AI
AI带来一些危机
什么才是一个更自动化的事
举一个自动化例子
就是比如说核武器就是
那核武器也是一个可以大家觉得哎
可能有毁灭世界力量的事
但核武器最后
最终受到控制的方法
就是Multi party control
这个世界上
大家有很多个有核武器的国家
他们互相都有毁灭对方的能力
所以通过这样一种制衡才稳定住
我觉得你要阻止AI干一些不好的事
可能
最终是需要一种类似的机制来实现的
而不是希望
寄希望说
一家公司制定一个法律来干一件事
嗯对
而且它自己制定
它也只能管得了自己
嗯你刚刚也提到
Anthropic有个可解释性团队
是吗
这个它的可解释性到达哪一步了
在一些比较简单
比较稀松的的的神经网络里面
它们能够做一些有趣的研究
比如说哎
看看某一个输出了
或者输入的的文字或者图片
它内在的表示是长成什么样的
然后你可能把那个表示什么反一下
之后它会能输出一个什么样的东西
做一下这样的研究
你刚才还提到一个观点
就是AI本质是简单的
你能不能描述一下这句话
这是一个结论
对我觉得这是这
这甚至不是一个结论
就是这是我的一个statement（陈述）
是我的一个陈述
它可对可错
哦然后我对这个
这是你的观点
对我对这个
我对这个陈述的的解释是
我觉得它本质上简单的点在于
它能做实验
就是它和比如说本质上难的东西
比如说物理
它的区别在于
那个东西
你没有那个能标下的实验数据
你就是理解不了那个能标下的理论
但是AI不被这个所bound（约束）
你理解不了没关系
我也可以往前发展
而且就是我现在
事实就是
能够做任何我能想到的实验
只是可能说
我需要一些时间
去把这个计算量提上来
或者把这个基础设施准备好
但是没有什么本质上的困难
对
所以我一直说就是
觉得AI就是没有给人感觉
它碰壁的原因就是
首先很多东西你都能试
其次
现在不是说大家已经想空了脑袋
没有什么想法可以试了
更多的情况下是有太多的想法
得一个个试
花时间
嗯
感觉人好渺小啊
在这个实验面前
是的 所以说
我觉得很快
可能AI就会开始自己做实验了
很快是多快
4个月内
我觉得未来的6-12个月
AI就会自己做实验
我觉得当然就是这话
不太良好定义
对不起我说了一个很模糊的话
就是嗯
AI自己提高自己
或者自己来加快自己的发展过程
这件事其实已经在发生了
对吧
就像我们刚才最早的时候聊过
就是它已经开始帮我们
能够去实现一些我们想要的东西
然后加快我们实验的速度
但是我觉得未来六到十二个
sorry
它目前还做不到的事情是什么
是说它能不能
从头到尾的把一件AI研究的事做完
就比如说它不仅能写这个code
它还能跑这个实验
跑这个实验
还能看到这个结果
看到这个结果
还能分析这个结果
分析这个结果
知道它哪儿做的不对
然后提出新的假设
设计新的代码
跑新的实验
这条链条目前还没有完整
但我觉得
这条链条
可能是下一步会慢慢变得完整的
基于你的各种原因
在你离开
决定离开Anthropic那一刻
你对这家公司未来的预期是什么呀
我觉得我离开的时候
我对这公司其实挺悲观的
但后来显然是我过度悲观了
呵呵呵为什么悲观
我当时悲观的原因是因为
我觉得我当时离开Anthropic的时候
Anthropic其实嗯
主要的收入来源都是API
就是卖Token
然后
这是个差生意
是个差生意
因为这个生意
只有对一个公司是好生意
就是Google
因为这个
这个生意最后就是得打价格战
就是eventually（最终）就是要打价格战
打价格战你没有完整的这个链条
是没有什么太多优势的啊
但是后来Anthropic显然在产品方面就是
我觉得确实有是有很多巧思
做了很多好的事儿
不管像是Claude Code也变得越来越好用了
然后Claude Cowork
然后和各种各样的
这种和工作和效率相关的事情
都慢慢汇聚起来了
所以感觉它现在反而变得比
我当时觉得
你要问我OpenAI和Anthropic哪个会先死
当然就不会真的死
就是哪个会先变得没那么重要
我当时会觉得哎
可能是Anthropic会先变得没那么重要
但是后来首先OpenAI被Google揍了一拳
然后Anthropic自己又上道了
所以现在看来好像Anthropic更占优势一些
哈哈
你后悔过没有
嗯不太后悔
我觉得对我个人来说
我个人的动机还是想要去换一个地方
提高自己
我觉得对这件
对于想做的这件事儿来说
这个选择没有什么错误
你也提到Anthropic的产品有很多巧思
特别是今年
像Cowork这些
这个来自于哪里啊
我觉得我没看到Cowork的发展过程
所以我不知道
然后Claude Code
我觉得人 产品
还可能
还真的是有一些个人英雄主义的机会
是研究员还是产品经理
Boris Cherny
那个我觉得Claude Code的几乎
至少这个事的开端吧
是他自己想要做这个事
提高自己或者同事的工作效率
最后变成了一个
对所有人都会很重要的事
Boris是一个什么样的人
我跟他没有太多的个人接触
我更多的只是看到他的工作 在公司的时候
他是个researcher是吧
对但他主要是在产品那边
所以Anthropic是有专门的产品部门的
以前没有分的那么开
后来有单独的
对 Anthropic感觉是很懂AI的产品呢
对我觉得
我觉得这就是为什么
刚才刚开始说的时候
觉得这个产品经理
可能还是目前挺难被AI取代的
哈哈哈嗯
好的产品经理
哎他好像不是上一代那种产品经理
他不是那种feature的摆放啊什么的
他好像是知道怎么跟AI协作的
某种产品经理
对我觉得上一代产品经理可能
但也不全是
上一代也有些
就是交互
交互方式级别的变化
但每一次交互方式级别变化
其实就带来一很大的产品
比如说就是可能这个抖音
就是一个交互方式级别改变的产品
那它一下就带来了很大的
嗯打开了新的方向
然后我觉得
可能Claude Code也是一个这样级别的产品
Claude Code和Cowork都是Boris
我不知道Cowork是谁做的
OK我已经离开了
I see
那说说你到了Google
DeepMind以后的工作吧
工作重心发生变化没有
嗯 还是
发生了一些变化的
然后
我反正我自己主要在站外
就是做ML coding
然后和一些比较long horizon的事
就是这两事
其实刚才都都大概提了一嘴
就是ML coding
其实它主要就是想要实现
刚才说的这个完整的AI
自己训练自己的这个历程
那当然这个过程当中
有很多实际的问题
有很多实际的细节要去解决
就是我觉得大的方向上来说
大家其实是比较有共识是该怎么去做
但是还是回到细节
就是细节上有很多要处理
比如说怎么样去选取合适的data
怎么样去还选取合适的回馈信号
以及它又带来新的基础设施的挑战
然后
现在就是要把这些事情要慢慢
慢慢摸清楚
然后
像long horizon
就是刚才说的另外一件事
就是说想要能够实现
说这个模型能够
在还是那句口号
train with finite
but use as infinite
我觉得想要把这个训练
的长度一直一直一直变长
可能并不是单个这个训练的
这个语段的长度一直变长
可能并不是一个很现实的方案
但是很现实的事儿是
你如何在有限的context下
去做更长的工作
其实你其实去想
人其实就是这个样子
人的context其实很短很短
你现在问我昨天晚上吃什么
我是一点也想不起来了
啊你可能还能想起来
哈哈哈我是一点也想不起来了
因为什么
因为它对我现在这个场景来说不关键
对吧
就是我现在知道昨天晚上吃什么
又能怎么样
所以我选择把它忘掉
所以人本质上context是很短
但他能够选择性的遗忘
然后让他选择性的对去retrieve（检索）
就是去把这些重要的
跟当前场景相关的信息再抓回来
所以说
我觉得那个可能也是一个对我来说
很有趣的这种方向
这两件事其实是有点有点相关
有点互补的
为什么 这两个事
其实都在模型使用工具和和环境
以及不同的模型
不同的人交互的这个大的范畴内
在这个范畴内
大家就过去完成的那个节点
就是Agentic coding 就是又是工具又和环境
环境就是这个虚拟机
或者你自己的电脑里这个做交互
然后这个事儿
其实它横向就会长出不同的使用场景
那做AI research
其实就是横向
这个场景里的另外一个场景啊
这个场景
它其实不仅横向上是一个新场景
它在纵向上
也让这个这个事情的尺度变得更长
因为你可能完成一个代码的补全之类
是一个很快的事
但你做一个完整的AI研究
或者做一个这种计算机科学的研究
那是一个很长的过程
对所以说
它其实就是像一个T字形一样
就是横向有延展
纵向也有延展
long horizon（长时序任务）是不是还是个科学问题啊
嗯有科学问题
也有工程问题
我觉得它的科学问题更多的是
怎么把不同的方案尝试一下
以更科学的方式尝试之后
来找到一条最后我们要走的
走的这个方案
这个有哪些方式
嗯
我可能不能说太细的
但粗的来说
从有一些方案是从pre-train的角度
从预训练角度来说
有一些方案
就是类似于这种稀疏的attention
sparse attention（稀疏注意力机制）
那这个比如DeepSeek也有一些工作
然后学界也有很多工作
然后从后训练的角度
也有后训练的方案
比如说像外界
比如说你每天用什么Cursor这些
他们就是很强的context management（上下文管理）
管理这个context能力
比如说它可以让这个模型去选择
我把这个中间某一段觉得不重要
就扔掉了
然后那一段重要就存在某个文件里
到时再取回来
这两种大的来说
这两种方案
都有人在研究
当然它具体实施细节
是不止我刚刚说的这些例子
刚刚说的这些例子
就是比较公开的例子
那具体实施细节
当然就每个公司还有自己的小秘密
哎我觉得其实也就是最终也都会
然后
我个人是比较花很多
更多时间在后训练的这部分的方案上
因为
当然首先
因为我自己
本来就没有花正式的工作时间在在预训练上
预训练对我来说更多是一个就是兴趣
我想学习的事
但我自己
其实没有在那上面做太多的工作
然后另一方面是
我觉得后训练的这个方案
其实更符合我自己对这个事的理解
就我对这个事的理解
就是刚才一直在说的这件事
就说能不能用短的context去训练
但是能做长context的事
预训练这些方案
其实本质上还是需要你有长context
训练它需要数据里有
对嗯
对对所以说
所以它不太符合我对这个问题的哲学
哦对
所以你现在看可以吗
用短的去训练长的
我觉得
可以是一定可以
但是我们不清楚哪个方案最有效
Gemini的长文本做得很好
为什么呀
有些技巧
哈哈哈哈哈哈
有一些让我很惊讶的技巧哈哈哈
哦 这是预训练的事是吧
长文本做的很好
一定是两边都有的
但是我只是说对我来说
预训练那边
那个技巧还是挺让我惊讶的
哈哈哈
对 OpenAI做的没有Gemini好
在长文本上
但是也有说法也不一样
就是有些人也说Gemini 3这一代
长文本反而变差了一点啊
之类的对
Again 你加入Gemini的时候
感觉大家对Gemini的预期不高
没 我对Gemini当时预期已经挺高的了
哈哈哈 你那是几几年几月
我是去年的9月底
那个是Gemini
放Gemini 3之前
你对它的预期高啊
其他人呢
我觉得业内的人
当时对Gemini都还是印象不错的吧
就是我觉得
之前一直觉得Google很有危机
在OpenAI的冲击之下
我觉得大家的感知
可能在Gemini 2.5这一代产生了变化
因为2.5是一个明显
你能看出来Google开始上道了啊
在当然之前就是Gemini的
1.5啊也有一些就是
小的事情
某一个具体的方面做的已经算很强了
就是很明显它已经不是很落后
但是2.5是真的
真的一代
就是我觉得开始有人开始用的模型
反正我自己其实也用过2.5
用的挺多的
你是看到2.5去的Gemini
我去Gemini跟这没关系
主要还是我知道
Gemini它大概是一个什么样的氛围
就是有很多人在做不一样的研究啊
然后我也知道一些人
其实
做研究很有意思
然后很多Gemini工程师
我觉得技术是非常非常非常强的
我觉得
我是从他们身上学到了非常非常多
然后嗯
对我来说那是原因
但是我觉得从大家的感知上来说
可能我觉得业内的人在看到Gemini 2.5之后
就可能就已经意识到了
说Gemini是要赶上来了
那对你来说
不是你加入了Gemini的一个信号是吧
不是我加入它的一个信号
那你为什么加入Gemini
那就刚才说的就是
主要是因为我当时想做事
其实我想要去有
但你知道
Gemini的人强
对吧 对对
那个是因为就是他们来
来找我的时候肯定也会让我去
去和他们的人去聊嘛
那从聊的过程中
其实是能够其实能看出来状态怎么样
哦是他们来找你
对
但是我觉得最后就变成双向奔赴了
所以哈哈哈
你当时OpenAI不是选择吗
如果你想从Anthropic离职
对OpenAI也是当时的选项
OpenAI当时应该还是比Gemini
那从势能上要强吧
在那个时候
但是
不过那个时候
是不是各种那个内部的内斗
内斗开始出现了
我觉得对
就是OpenAI确实也是我当时的一个选项
然后当然还包括像xAI之类的
然后我觉得
OpenAI最后没有去的一个主要原因
还是我对它的
文化至少当时来看
我对它的文化是有比较大的担心的
就是我觉得
用粗话来说 就是感觉踏实做事
踏实做事的人没有Gemini多
也更没有Anthropic的人多
对哦 这个我很care
哈哈哈对
所以一种文化和人的亲近感让你去了Gemini
对
然后你又赶上了到Gemini 3的那个转折点是吗
嗯
Gemini 3应该对它来说是一个很大的转折的
一个时期是吗
我觉得从实际的效果来说
我觉得是两件事
让Gemini产生了一个大的转折
就变成了一个市场里举足轻重的
player（玩家）的
玩家是Nano Banana
Nano Banana和Gemini 3
两件事连着 就是你
我觉得如果只有Gemini 3
可能也不会有现在这么好的效果
因为当你的市占率连
10%都不到的时候
你这个模型好一点坏一点
其实等它传播出去就是太慢了
但是Nano Banana做到的一件事是
首先市场上这件事很爆很爆款
然后大量的人去下载了Gemini的APP
然后Gemini 3又紧接着放
把这个部分留下来了
所以
现在它变成了一个举足轻重的玩家
觉得可能就是没有Gemini打这么一拳
那其实OpenAI的位置很爽
就它市占率已经高到
你其实模型上干点啥
对它来说可能影响都没那么大啊
甚至说实话
我觉得就是真正普通人用模型的时候
对模型的这个能力的感知
其实是很弱很弱的
绝大多数人甚至都不用o系列模型
绝大多数人都用普通的
那个ChatGPT的
对所以说我觉得对于Genimi来说
这个一个Nano Banana把量打起来
然后Gemini 3又把人留回来
是一个很关键的事
它有事实上抢走多少ChatGPT的用户
嗯我不知道现在具体的比例
但是我的感觉是
Gemini可能市占会在20%左右吧
但是我确实没有仔细去检查过现在的数据
这是从事后归因来看
这两个因素
共同促成了Gemini今天对于OpenAI的冲击
那你从内部视角肯定能更前置的知道
为什么就发生了什么
Google会有这样的变化
对我觉得
我觉得首先就是Google的这个技术储备
一直是够
嗯人够
对 一直是够的
然后
组织上来说
后来变得越来越清晰了
就是有一个更好的框架来让
大家干一起干这个事了
所以说可能会慢慢慢慢有些进展
对然后
我觉得从某种意义上来说
我作为一个局外人
从某种意义上来说
我觉得OpenAI是救了Google一命
哦 就是因为大家以前一直都担心说
这个聊天机器人
会不会完全把搜索取代掉
对如果这个事真的发生了
Google其实很难受
但是好在呢
就是OpenAI先把这个事做了
然后让Google意识到了这个事很重要
但是它又没有把这个事做到底
又没有把这个事做到极致
又完全没有完全把search搜索干掉
可能就吃掉了一些份额
结果
让Google自己把聊天机器人也追上来了
那现在难受就是它了
你要万一
比如说有一个公司就假如说啊
在一个虚构世界
有一个公司不仅做了chatbot
而且还一路高歌猛进
越做越好
真的一把就把你搜索吃掉了
完全没有给你反击的机会
那就很难受了
那chatbot没有吃掉搜索
是因为OpenAI干的不好
还是为什么呢
还是因为这个干不掉搜索
我觉得
两方面其实都有
就是说首先嗯
目前的chatbot这种交互方式
其实不会完全吃掉搜索
因为它比搜索强
就像刚刚最早时候说过
它比搜索强的一点
是说它有很强交互性
你可以追问
然后
它可以帮你把一些很复杂的信息去浓缩
这是它很强的地方
所以这部分使用场景
它确实会把搜索的人抢掉但
搜索里还有一些非常愚蠢的场景
就是你有一个特别简单的事
你根本不想浪费这个时间
在聊天机器人身上啊
比如说我就是
我就搜买大米
我就一搜买就完了
就
我还非得去问ChatGPT
我还得非得问哪个好
然后它还在那转圈圈
圈圈转半天
然后给你个链接
你再一点
再跑到网页再去买
对吧没有那个必要
所以说从事实的使用上来说
它目前的形态
并不足以把搜索完全吃掉
对然后
当然从另一个角度上来说
它可能在聊天机器人这个事情上
也没有做到登峰造极
就它还真的让Google把它给赶上了
现在还不算赶上吧
在产品上
我觉得在产品上不算赶上
但是在模型上已经是赶上了
但是要投资人投OpenAI
他们会说
他们下注的时候
是认清楚
OpenAI其实是个产品公司的时候
它的护城河其实是产品和品牌
那从今天来看的话
似乎Google还没有在这件事情上能够
赶上
不能说超越OpenAI吧
赶上OpenAI吧
对就是我觉得
这其实是
反正这都是我作为一个局外人
观察者的视角来说
你今天是点评家
哈哈哈
观察者的角度来说
我觉得Google传统上在产品就是有点慢
是一直都比较慢啊
然后所以
你说OpenAI会不会在产品上有优势
我觉得是有可能的
对
然后Google特别擅长的一件事是什么
是找到一个极为简单的产品形态
大家都长一个样
它就疯狂给你卷技术
你就卷不过它
哦对
就那个事是Google擅长的
因为搜索引擎就是这样的一个事儿
搜索就是一个典型的
就是大家都是一个框
一个键 但它就是比你搜的快
搜的比你准
你拿它一点办法也没有
嗯
所以这就是为什么
就是
感觉一直以来
Google都处于一个做的很好但
华尔街都不太认可的状态
大家总觉得这公司壁垒到底在哪
也没有什么产品的巧思
也没有什么留存的机制
但它就活到了现在
哎所以它技术好的原因是啥
我觉得还是就人好吗
我觉得还是氛围吧
就说是一个
特别特别重视
以前就是特别重视工程师
后来就是特别重视研究的
这样一个氛围
所以它很适合
那种通过技术能力溢出的产品
能力的产品
对如果从这个角度来看的话
那你觉得OpenAI的位置是稳固的吗
现在
我觉得现在谁的位置都不稳固
哈哈哈哈哈对
我觉得就是AI的形态
还有很长的路要走
嗯
没有到什么终局之战
这个地方的感觉呢
对
感觉国内已经有点儿这意思了
对我不理解
就是为什么不理解
我很费解
就是
那国内觉得我们在争夺一个superapp
superapp就是此消彼长的呀
我觉得condition on聊天机器人这个事儿（把聊天机器人
作为条件来构建）就是superapp
那可能可以争夺一下
但是问题是
你这个形态是不是super app那个形态
会不会别人
就是哪天出了一个完全不一样的形态
然后你的功能变成了那个东西
一个子集
这是很有可能的是吗
我觉得没有什么
我觉得我看不出什么不可能
为啥chatbot不是那个终极形态
但是这么多年我们也就看到这个了
对就是 都是一个对话框
我觉得在这个事上我确实没有什么
没有什么理性或者量化的标准
来说明
更多的是你觉得这个事很蠢
就是这个模型明明有那么多的能力
但居然用的方法是chatbot（注：本次视频录制于2个多月前，此时Agent的形态还未明朗）
就是不太make sense
知道吧所以
需要一个产品经理
来解放一下模型的能力
哈哈哈
人类到现在只通过chatbot去跟AI沟通
让你觉得很蠢是吧
很蠢就是
那应该用什么去跟AI沟通
没想明白
要想明白我就干了
哈哈哈哈哈
哎你没有告诉我
Google内部到底发生了什么变化
然后有了外界看到的
模型能力的突飞猛进
对就是刚才说就一个
我觉得组织上更清楚了
然后
组织上一旦清楚的话
组织变化了吗
对
尤其像预训练
现在变得非常非常清楚
就是谁负责什么事情
然后每一个点
每一个这个节点上谁是负责人
这些事情都很清楚
以前是混沌的吗
以前最早的时候很乱
我没有最早时候在那待过
但是就是同事
根据同事或者我以前认识的人的描述
以前还是更混乱一些的
嗯对对
然后现在就是
至少预训练也是变得非常非常清楚
然后加上
这个这Google
一直有的
这种就是比较强的技术背景
然后它做事也比较系统
所以觉得
预训练在Google
是一个非常非常可控的事
嗯可预测的事
你就你能够
你能知道
下一代不会差
哦可能你还会知道它会有多好
通过Anthropic这种自上而下的管理它也
嗯不错
那Google是这种自下而上的
它依然是自下而上的是吗
它比以前肯定要更自上而下了
比起最早的时候
但是它比Anthropic来说
还是更自下而上了一些
就好像不同的文化都可以
是吗对
就是对于模型的训练
对就是
就是我觉得大公司有大公司的打法
startup有startup的打法
所以大公司是
你刚刚也说
它是一个完全不一样的叙事
它是一个不一样的
方法 Google是什么方法
现在我觉得Google更多的说是
像这种比较确定性的事
比如像预训练
已经是一个比较确定性的范式了
那可能Google就会更像
把它做成一个工程项目
Google的工程管理能力又很强
所以说它就能慢慢把它做好
嗯什么叫工程项目
工程项目的意思就是
你其实是
其实是非常非常
非常top down（自上而下）的一个组织
然后很清楚
我们下一阶段要做的是什么事情
然后去做这个事情
中间需要有哪几个节点被处理掉
然后哪怕是做研究也是说
就是有一个很清晰的框架
告诉你怎么去
验证你的结果是好是坏
evaluate（评估）你的结果是好是坏
对所以这个是
是Google很强的事情
在过去的任何的一个大的工程项目上
所以说预训练
其实我觉得就是现在进入到Google
Google的舒适区里了啊
然后
后训练当然就是有很更多的不确定性
那可能后训练现在来说
还是更bottom up（自下而上）一点
就大家可以更广泛的试
你说pre-train也是一种RL
为什么这么说
我觉得就是
你很难从纯技术的角度说
pre-train就是预训练
或者说这个监督学习
SFT和RL的本质区别是什么
因为预训练和SFT
当然预训练和SFT本质也没啥区别
就是
你无非就是把你拿到的那些数据
当成你的ground truth
然后你就把那个当成你的expert
把那个当成你的专家输出
然后你朝那个专家输出的的分布上靠
强化学习可能就是更宽广的一个级别
一个级它就是说我首先就是这个
这个本来输出的东西
也不是一个给定的专家
而是我自己产生的一些东西
然后我里面也有好的结果
也有不好的结果
然后好的结果要往上靠
不好的结果要远离它 之类的这样东西
所以说从某种意义上来说
pre-training和SFT是强化学习的一个子集
但是呢
这两件事确实在现在这个时代
是有区别的
当然我觉得对我来说
它的最大区别在数据上
就是pre-training的数据
更多的还是要distribution够好
就是分布足够的广或者足够符合
你想要覆盖住的那些范围
但是数据的质量
并不需要非常非常的高
但是后训练呢
是反过来
就是说它分布上来说可能要远窄
但是它在有的那些数据质量上
会要求非常高
嗯对
所以我觉得目前来说
对我来说
它俩最本质区别
还是在数据分布上的区别
而不是在算法或者训练范式上的区别
那像不同的lab
它是怎么分这个组的呀
预训练和后训练有不同吗
还是都一样
Anthropic
和Google比较类似
两个都是
就是预训练是预训练一个组
然后后训练是后训练一个组嗯
OpenAI可能比较混沌
最早的时候
我一开始的时候它是分三个组
就是它有预训练
然后它还有强化学习
就是Strawberry草莓组
然后它还有一个post-training组
然后我的
我没在那干过
但我的理解是
它的post-training其实是就不是
它的那个RL组就Strawberry
和它的post-training
其实是别的公司的post-training和产品
哦然后
它可能是以这种不一样的方式
给它切了
它把后续人当产品做
就是它的一部分
后训练其实是和产品
是在做产品
它是不是只是名字没改过来呢
也不完全是
因为
绝大多数公司的产品
其实不太训模型了
它更多的是把这个需要的
这个特质
模型特质告诉训练模型的团队
但是它好像就是它的post-training
从某种意义上说自己又是产品
但自己又能训模型
这是不是
它对于产品的理解就是
需要训练模型的人来做产品
对对对有可能
有可能是件好事
对但是它后来也这个组织变化很多
所以
我现在也不知道他们组织成啥样了
你们最近发了几个模型
然后我看到你也都参与其中
Gemini 3 Deep Think
Gemini 3.1 Pro
那我觉得可能
只能说是有幸参与
哈哈哈哈哈对
again就是感觉都是集体工作
哈哈哈哈哈哎
你为什么现在都变成了明星人物
每次都被拎出来单独写一下
我不明白
我觉得其实不太好
每次看到之后
我都感觉
明天该怎么去办公室见同事呢
哈哈哈哈
会有异样吗
在办公室就还好
我觉得同事可能还是人比较好
就是
他们可能也不是特别看重这些事啊
但说实话
我是觉得我参与过的任何一个项目
不管是在Google还是在Anthropic
没有我都会发生
都一样会发生
效果也不不不
会变差
我这是
我觉得大家现在就是
是每个人都是冲浪的人
本质上是一个浪
而不是你那个冲浪的人
嗯 浪是AI吗
对就是AI
这个这个事情本身是是这个浪
它会往前走
不管你冲不冲这个浪
这个浪都会拍到岸上
只是说有人可能就冲了这个浪
有人就可能晚了一点
没赶上那个浪尖
好
你有幸的参与了这两个工作的
什么
主要可能就是一些有一些
那个就是算法上设计的小的细节
然后就会一
块讨论呀
然后
有一些
有一些数据上的东西
但是数据上的东西
我觉得
可能对之后的工作会影响更大一些
这几个模型有范式变化吗
嗯我觉得没有哪个
没有哪个变化大到了
从不知道怎么做大尺度的强化学习
到大尺度强化学习
那个级别的变化
没有哪个变化大到这个地步
肯定都是会有一些小小的变化
这几个小小变化你能讲一讲吗
就这几个新的模型
肯定都是会有一些小小的变化
最近我感觉模型已经发麻了
国内一堆模型
国外也是很多模型
OpenAI你们
嗯国内GLM（智谱） 字节
DeepSeek一直期待还没发（注：目前DeepSeek 4已发）
Kimi 你能不能给大家划划重点啊
我觉得
从某种意义上来说
都没那么值得关注
哎大家在争什么现在
感觉群魔乱斗
我觉得有一些争的事情呢
其实现在看来
已经在这个时代
已经没那么重要了
就是因为过去带来的惯性
是大家会争各个Benchmark的第一名
证明自己模型的基本能力很强啊
这个事情呢
其实到现在已经到了
就是公众关注
那些Benchmark都有点打满了
其实你想最早大家关注这个SWE-bench
随便大家都打到80多
幸亏没有人超过83
因为最近OpenAI刚放一个post说超过83
那个有的题目都是不良好定义的
幸亏没人超过吧
谁超过谁尴尬
反正啊
然后大家以前Reasoning就是打完AIME打IMO
打完IMO打什么
想不成RKGI啊这些
Benchmark然后RKGI
嗯在Gemini 3
之前大家可能最高的都忘了
那时候可能十级这样子吧
然后大家就哇
登天难
然后Gemini 3给变成30多了
然后Claude 4.5还是4.6变成哎
4.6应该是变成60多了
然后Gemini 3 Deep Think一下打到80多
所以这个也打满
所以现在就是感觉
光靠打这种公众认知的模型能力
其实已经没啥太大的意思了啊
然后嗯
所以从这个角度上说
我就是
本质上就是没有什么太多的重点啊
虽然大家发的很快哈
嗯
发的快也说明
其实这道题对大家所有人来说
都变简单了
大家都知道knowhow了
没有什么秘密了已经
对对
就是还是说还是这个
就还是那个
冲浪理论嘛
就是还是这个
浪在往前走
大家下一个可能在寻找的目标是什么
下一个范式级的变化是什么
还会有吗
啊我觉得
我刚才自己聊的那两个事是
我觉得ML coding和long horizon对
然后这两个是
我觉得我觉得
嗯
是是
我觉得是一个可能没有到范式级变化
但是我觉得是
对于Google来说会很有价值的事情
因为首先ML coding是
因为
Google首先自己是一个AI research大户
然后它自己又是AI research最全栈的
就是它
不仅有这些训练模型这些这些部分
它还有设计硬件的部分
从硬件接到模型的部分
这一整套东西如果能被加速
或者说被更好的管理
那可能对这个公司来说是很有价值
long horizon就不说了
就所有人都知
就所有人都很都都都觉得很重要
对
所以说我觉得那个可能是对我来说
不能说是范式级别的
绝对是不到范式级别
但是一个我觉得是很有价值
需要去在未来几个月之内能够
能够看到曙光的事然后嗯
我觉得范式级
可能就还是那些更非确定性的东西
就是什么多模态生成那个
我觉得可能会有一个英雄吧
或者会有一个英雄集体吧
哈哈哈然后嗯对
像那种可能会有一些
嗯还有聊比较多的continue learning（持续学习）
世界模型呢
我觉得continue learning和这种long horizon
刚刚说long horizon没有本质的区别
因为嗯
因为大家以前觉得这两事儿差别很大
是因为
continue learning会改变模型的一些权重
然后你做这种
比如说像开放
开源了
大家做很多这种
这种context management（上下文管理）
是不会改变变模型权重的
但其实你想这两事儿没有本质区别
因为context里那些词
自己的KV不也是一种权重吗
所以说
你觉得这两个方案就是最后谁能
谁能更有用
在长久来说更有用
我觉得是不清楚的
但是他们本质上
都是为了做刚才lone horizon
这种类型的事情
然后世界模型
一万个人有一万个世界模型
啥意思 就是定义不清晰
就是
首先我不知道什么叫做一个世界模型
其次就是
每个人在说他们做的世界模型的时候
可能也在说不一样的事儿
比如说Gemini做的世界模型可能就和
比如说像
李飞飞
她们做的世界模型就不是一个事
嗯唉
描述一下区别是
我不是特别了解像外面像李飞飞啊
她们这些lab做的事情
到底是怎么样的
但是嗯
Gemini的世界模型更多的是一种
是一种end to end（端到端）的这种级别的训练
它想要的结果是说我一个
比如视频生成
是大家能够给定一个描述
然后生成一个视频
但它想要的达到结果是
我不仅能够生成一个视频
我是能够生成一个场景
什么叫一个场景
场景就是说我生成了
这个时刻的状态
然后我还可以再给它一个condition
一个条件
这条件是我在这个状态下做了一样
什么样的
动作
然后它下一个时刻状态
会变成我上一个时刻
状态和动作的函数啊
然后它是end to end去训练这样的能力
对所以说这个可能是一种方案
然后我
我首先也不知道
大家最后想要的到底什么结果
然后我也不知道大家
对自己世界模型的定义到底是什么
所以我觉得更多还是一种探索状态
刚才我们一直没有聊到一个组织是xAI
我们刚才聊了Anthropic
聊了OpenAI
聊了DeepMind
那xAI呢
xAI我是不明白哈哈哈
作为点评家来说一下
他们怎么最近这么动荡
我觉得他们一直都挺动荡
哈哈哈那为什么最近这么动荡
我也不知道啊
然后
我其实我跟xAI接触的没有那么多
我接触的一些人现在也走了
其实我也不知道他们发生了啥
哈哈哈
你刚才说Anthropic的时候
你说
技术的一号位能make bets
是非常重要的
那在Google这样的一号位是谁啊
这个英雄是谁啊
我觉得英雄
可能在不同的阶段是不一样的人
嗯但是英雄的背后都有一个人
就是Sergey Brin
就是Google的那个cofounder
哦对
就是我觉得最终很多很多大的决定
可能不是由他来决定怎么做
但是最后拍那个板得他来拍
嗯现在也是
Demis Hassabis呢
我觉得可能更多的在一线出现的
是Koray Kavukcuoglu
对
就是是
DeepMind CTO
然后他现在也是那个Google的SVP
哦Demis在负责什么
我觉得Demis可能管了更多那种
就是偏science的事情
就比如说那个药物的design
Isomorphic Labs啊那些事情
对对对
哦Gemini
他管的不多
至少从我的视角来说
我看到的更多的人是Koray
当然有可能就是那
那公司那个管理层的事
其实有很多是我看不到的部分
那我就不清楚了
你刚才也提到AI是整个是一个系统嘛
嗯
你对于怎么系统性的做AI
有什么认知吗现在
经过了你这两年的工作
有几方面吧
一方面是从从整个系统来说
它需要一种比较科学的态度
就是你要清楚地像Scaling Law
你要清楚地理解
自己做了什么样的预设
然后我在做一个改变的时候
其实有哪些因素是和它相关联
哪些因素是不相关联的
对
然后这是从组织情况下来说
从人的情况下来说
其实需要人很reliable
就是需要很负责任的人
其实每一个系统
就每一个评价的框架
都是很容易被hack（钻空子）的
因为你总可以做一些事
让你的指标看起来很好看
但是一个值得信赖
或者踏实的人
他其实是会想
自己做的这件事如果效果好的话
是不是真的
比如说在大的尺度上效果好
是不是我中间漏了哪些因素
对
其实把事做系统
听起来是一句话
但真正做起来是很复杂的事
就是有很多细节
有很多阻力会
它其实是违背人性的
哦
因为每个人个人的人性
可能都是为了让我自己做的东西
能够体现的更好
但是对一个公司或者一个组织来说
最有利的事
是把整个公司的系统
系统性做的非常扎实
非常严谨
这个能不能举点例子呀
好像有点抽象
对 它确实有点抽象
这也是你说
没有那么多的
个人英雄主义的一个表现
对
就人要变成一个更可信可靠的一个
他是一个系统的组件
我可以举一个
一个可能也是比较鬼话的例子
就是 比如说做强化学习
你可能可以做一个算法
出来效果比别人好
但是可能更关键问题是你要去问
比如说在真正的大的尺度下
我是不是能够保持稳定性
是一样好的
然后以及我比
别人的东西效果好
是不是因为我用了不一样的data
以及我是不是用了更多的training的flops
是不是用了更多的sampling的flops
然后我具体在真的这个
生产的这个
最后这个大的跑的这个production run（最终的大规模训练）
里面到底哪个才是我的限制因素
然后我该看选哪个指标
这个其实可能都是
需要研究员自己对于这个系统
怎么运作
有一个好的理解
然后以及对公司负责任才能做到
否则就是你很容易做到一件事
就是
你可能比如说你在考虑training的时候
是比别人好的
但你考虑training加sampling时候比别人差
你总可以选择你只是有training
但这就很糟糕
对
所以这个就是既需要你个人的负责任
又需要说组织所建立的这个体系里
能够能尽量的发现这些
有意的或者无意的
这种边界的事情
但是你作为个体的话
你不知道怎么样是对全局最好的呀
其实是需要
我觉得如果一个研究员做不到
对全局去考虑的话
他就不是一个好的研究员
在现在这个时代
嗯 就是这个
我觉得这个
和你就是在学术界做research
是很不一样的事
哦
因为在学术界做research
本质上是一个人吃饱
全家不愁的状态
这我为我的项目负责对吧
我为我的可重复性负责
但是在一个公司里
你其实更多的时候是
我得为这个公司负责
这是两种完全不一样的心态
那你这种自觉性从哪里来的
不知道哈哈哈哈哈
我觉得我可能就是拉不下脸
哈哈哈
拉不下脸是什么
就是
你对一个公司负责任
是你和这个公司的契约的一部分
其实我觉得没什么道理不这么做
这么做是没有原因的
所以这个人英雄主义会破坏这种整体性
我觉得
如果只是为了个人英雄主义
而做事的话
很有可能是会破坏整体性
当然实际可能你能力很强
然后你真的成了一个英雄
那也是有可能
因为你也经历了两个组织了
你觉得什么样的组织更能够激发智能
在这个时代
我觉得
其实这是一个
很有争议的事
就说
因为刚才也聊了
就是不同组织
可能有些比较比较自上而下
有些比较自下而上
那一个自然问题说
比如说
这两种组织哪个更能够激发创新
过去的观点就是
自下而上是激发创新必要条件
因为就是你得每个人有自由嘛
有自由才能有创新
但是完全自下而上
你发现其实也不行
因为它就乱
那就是Google之前的样子
是吗
对
至少在我印象里
在我了解到的印象里是这样
就是它就乱
就是大家甚至都不知道
我做这个事有什么用
那可能也不好
所以就可能要需要有一个人
或者有一个小的集体
能够把这两件事稍微融合一下
嗯
这就是为什么我觉得
其实一个组织运行的好不好
看起来是组织的问题
但其实归根结底是技术leader的问题
嗯
就是这个技术leader有没有特质
能够把这个组织运行的很稳定
因为最好的那个状态
往往都是最不稳定的一个状态
就很容易往不好的那个方向塌缩的
对 所以得有一个leader来控制这个事
那你觉得都是技术leader来做这个事情
而不是CEO来做这个事情
那当然每个公司的CEO
可能有不一样的职责
但是得有一个leader
我觉得至少得有一个leader
他能有两个特质
才能去做这个事
一个特质就是说他自己有救火的能力
不是说他光嘴上说要做什么
要做什么
而是说有一件事真的遇到困难了
他能自己下场去带人
把这个困难解决掉
当然绝大多数时候
可能一个leader
是不会有时间去做这个事儿
但他至少有这个能力
第二个重要特质
就是他得能够理解别人
就哪怕一件事
可能是他不做的事
但他能够理解到
为什么别人做那事重要
能够容得下别人
那可能是另外一个特质
你觉得Google的TPU
在哪些方面表现的比GPU更好
劣势是什么
我觉得
从纯硬件的角度来说
很难说哪种硬件真的好或者坏
尤其是在这种大规模商用的情况下
因为本质上来说
GPU和TPU
在使用上来说
最大的区别就是刨掉
硬件的区别来说
使用上来说
最大的区别就是
GPU它有比较好的开源生态
TPU没有
但这个事其实在大规模商用的时候
并不是一个问题
因为比如Google自己用TPU
那自然会花时间去搭
这个基础设施
而基础设施就是是一个
你可能比如说你只跑1000张卡
可能是一个很大的负担
但你跑一个几十万张卡的集群
那搭一个基础设施
也不是一个多大的事
然后从实际
所以就是
从实际上这种大规模商用来说
没有哪个孰优孰劣
但是这两个确实
有一些设计理念上的区别
比如说GPU
至少我可能后来这几代GPU
没怎么用过
像比如像Hopper那代GPU
H系列GPU
它的设计是说
我一个Pod（节点）里面
可能没有多少张卡
比如说就8张卡
然后这8张卡之间可以两两互联
NV link（英伟达高速互联总线）非常快
所以这一个pod几乎就是没什么
没有什么communication的bandwidth（GPU之间的通信带宽不足）
但是TPU它可能就反过来
它就是说
我抛弃了卡与卡之间两两互联
但是我能尽量的
把尽量多的卡
放在一个大的这个架子里面
它就是有这种
这个三维Torus的这种设计（3D Torus 拓扑设计）
所以它就一张卡
就只有在三个方向连3个最近邻的
但是它整个集群可以连成一个大
Torus
然后如果你的compilers（编译器）
或者你的那个sharding（数据的分片策略）的
逻辑写得足够好的话
你是可以利用这样的东西
其实就等效来说
你会获得更大的储存空间
然后也会减少很多通信的bound
劣势是什么呀
我觉得一个劣势就是
它肯定是比起GPU来说
至少在小的scale上来说
比起GPU是更加
更加固定的一种结构吧
所以说它的易用性
或者它的通用性可能没有那么强
最近硅谷有很多neo lab出现
你怎么看这个趋势
为什么他们都出去
从这些模型大厂跳出去
成立neo lab
我看不太懂
哈哈哈 我的感觉是
绝大多数的neo lab都会死 然后
那个我觉得就是
可能有一些lab是真的有好的人的
然后像有些lab
可能确实也开始在做一些事
比如说像thinking machine
还是在deliver一些新的东西的
然后但有些neolab就是
请帮我把名字哔掉
哈哈哈比如说XXX那个XXX
我就完全不知道他们到底要干嘛
然后
这俩人其实已经远离这个专业好久了
我觉得26年
国内会非常的看重C端的叙事
谁成为那个super app
你怎么看
你觉得这个
这好像在硅谷没有人讲这个事儿
对 就是因为美国enterprise就是这个
就是公司
然后或者说效率软件这个市场太大
而且利润也太高
所以说对于美国来说
其实C端之前就只有ChatGPT一家做
然后其实也没啥油水
没有什么利润
所以说就是
现在大家可能重心都会先放在这种
效率软件
或者enterprise上
然后
所以中美的趋势已经发生差异化了
我觉得
不只是AI
也就是过去的整个互联网都是
都不一样
就是中国很强的就是C端
就是它能够想出一些哎
非常非常复杂的产品的的性质
或者结构
然后用一种很你觉得很间接
很不自然的方式
把这个利润滚起来
比如说
什么叫很间接
哈哈哈
就比如说像抖音这种东西
它并不是说
你看视频
我看一个视频收你两毛钱对吧
它说你可以免费看视频
但是我可以偷偷加广告
我可以偷偷做直播
我可以偷偷做电商
但是这个做效率软件没这事做
效率软件非常直接
就是我让你帮你写code
我成本一个月150
卖你200 我挣50
就是非常直接的事
嗯
对 我觉得美国在过去的体现
就是在这种很直接的产品上
能够把技术做到极致
但是一直没有
哪个产品让我觉得就是复杂到
说让你离不开它
你又感觉不到它在挣你的钱
但它实际上挣了你的钱
你这么说我突然觉得Meta就应该抄字节做
对但我觉得Meta没字节强
因为Meta它也找不到自己的生态位
然后
美国又没有一个做这件事情的公司
豆包这个生态位还没有人找到
那Meta就抄豆包呗
它也不需要那么强的模型能力啊
但我觉得还是美国做产品的
本质上做C端产品的人不行
比中国来说差远了
这是过去十年的积累是吗
对
嗯
因为过去十年在美国的这个正反馈
都来自于做ToB的
很多enterprise的事情
或者就是在美国这地方挣钱太容易
嗯
挣钱太容易的时候
你就不会费脑筋去想怎么挣钱
哎
不是很多人来 都要找你聊聊吗
有什么好玩的人啊
哦不
很多国内的人来
科技公司来
我觉得都挺好玩的
然后确实发现国内的人做产品
可能还是想法更复杂一些
更复杂一些
对就是想的更这个
想的这个回路更长一些
对跟美国还是风格不太一样
美国是
美国就刚才说了嘛
就是
做了什么就拿这个卖钱
对啊就是简单啊
就是这个事儿
就是需要这个能力
有了这个能力之后就是要比别人便宜
我就能挣得比你多
拿我一点办法也没有
好
中国呢
中国感觉都是这种
什么一开始不挣钱
但一旦它开始挣钱
你就拦不住它啊
就是它
是真的能形成那个
那个自己的那个
那个圈儿的
就是它真的把那个圈儿转起来的时候
你再想往里插就插不进去了
你觉得美国公司
现在看懂字节跳动没有
我的感觉是没有
还没有
它都这么大了
哦 你说是不是重视它
那肯定是重视的
就大家肯定都知道
字节是一家被严重低估
从它的市值上来说
是被严重低估的公司
这是我觉得大家很明确的事
然后
我觉得也很明确
就是说在消费者市场
这一端其实我觉得
没有哪个美国公司能和字节竞争的
但是它毕竟是一家中国公司
至少从公众意识上来说
它毕竟是家中国公司
所以看懂它了吗
我不觉得大家看懂了
但是你看Meta
其实也在主动的从字节挖人嘛
嗯 你在AI行业有什么偶像吗
或者欣赏的人
虽然你在AI行业很短
没没没啥
就是我感觉
我来这行业的时候
个人英雄主义时代已经过去了
所以也没有什么英雄
有时候你甚至觉得旧时代英雄有点蠢
啊 对
所以说真的没有什么
你觉得谁比较蠢
这个还是不说了吧
no comment哈哈哈哈哈哈
对 我觉得和
做物理时候还是不一样
我觉得做物理时候
还是存在着一些
我觉得真的比我聪明太多的人
比如我
我读博的时候我那个年轻老板就是
我觉得他Douglas Stanford
我觉得他就比我聪明太多了
我觉得他
可能也是看到他
我才觉得自己在那个领域也
没什么用
有他了还要我干嘛呢
对吧 哈哈
你跑到AI来降维打击一下是吧
也没降维打击
但是反正就感觉AI这个事
本来也不太需要脑子
不太需要脑子
真的不太需要脑子
那需要什么
我觉得这个
这个行业就是最重要的特质
就是靠谱
就是做事细
然后对自己做的事负责任
这是最重要的特质
你说那些东西有多需要脑子我觉得
都是一些本科生就能干的活
可是你说AI没有个人英雄主义
现在一个AI研究员的价格炒的多高啊
跟球星转会一样
我不知道是好事还是坏事
对我个人来说
我当然很高兴
我受益于这个
对吧呵呵呵
但是 嗯
实际上来说
我并不知道这个事
是不是一件好事
你觉得为什么价格会变得这么高
我觉得可能一方面是
大家觉得这个事很稀缺吧
但是他实际上可能确实也没那么充足
就是因为训练一个人
虽然这事没那么难
但是你训练一个人是需要一个环境的
就是你得有那个机会去接触这件事
你才能学会这件事
你没有那个机会
你就是再聪明也没用
那可能过去能撞到这个机会的人
没有那么多
所以说在市场上来说可能是比较稀缺
从这个角度上来说
嗯
但我觉得另一方面也是
可能对人的炒作有点过分了
对
非常喜欢神话个体
现在
对 我觉得
真的
就是再说一次
这是个集体主义的事哈哈哈
那很多人也会很好奇
因为
可能很多公司也想招AI的人
那你觉得最重要的还是要靠谱
这个有什么衡量指标呢
就怎么能够快速的判断一个人靠不靠谱
做事细不细
每个人都有一些自己衡量的方法
我当然也有一些自己的trick（诀窍）
就是我
我以前反正有出一道面试题
然后那个我大概讲一下
这个
应该不涉密
所以我应该可以讲
嗯
那面试题其实很简单
就是说我需要这个人在24小时之内
然后完成一个强化学习的项目
从0到1
就是他要自己去选用
什么样的模型
我告诉他有的资源是什么样的
然后他自己选用什么样的模型
用什么数据
用什么样的算法
然后把这个模型训出来
24小时之内
就是我给他让他24小时去完成这个事
然后24小时结束之后
他会跟我有一个小时的讨论
然后这个事儿呢
其实在AI时代没有那么难
没有AI时候
这是不可能的
没有人从24小时之内把它做出来
但有AI之后其实特别简单
因为AI能帮你全套做
但为什么还要做这个事儿呢
有两个原因
有很多原因啊
其中
设计成这样的两个原因
一个原因是因为我觉得在这个时代去
还去考察别人
比如说代码写得好不好
其实没用
因为绝大多数人都不用自己写代码
然后他更重要的是
他能不能有效地利用AI
那这个是一个方面的考察这个问题
第二方面是这个事其实有一个陷阱
就是如果你全盘让AI做了
但你最后没有试图好好理解
AI为你做了什么
那在那一个小时的讨论里面会露馅儿
那是一个
那个是一个会挂人的地方
对所以说那个考验的另一件事
就是说你有没有真的和AI形成了协作
还是说你就全权扔给他
那个是我觉得我个人很看重的事
那个其实也是
他就是这个人
是不是做事靠谱的的一部分
当然这个就这个
这个题目的设计本身
也有一些比较阴暗的巧思
就是说为什么设计成24小时
就是为了看这个人有多看重这个机会
能熬夜
对哈哈哈
如果他足够熬夜
他就能撑住这24个小时
如果他撑不住
那只能说
他可能对这个机会也没有那么看重
哈哈
那对于比你更年轻的人
你觉得他们现在来AI
还是一个很蓝海
就是很有机会的地方
我觉得纯做语言模型
已经不是一个蓝海了
我觉得晚了就是末班车已经发车了
末班车已经发车
末班那班是哪一班啊
我感觉我入行就是那个末班车啊
然后可能有确实在我入行之后当
然还有些新的人
但我觉得
他们就没有机会
能接触那么好的机会了
就是能在一个还
没有那么大的团体里做一件事情
那么可能就很少能遇到这样的机会了
对然后
但是我觉得就是AI
它是一个很很大的方向
语言模型只是其中的很小很小一个
很小一个部分
还有很多别的事情
比如刚刚说的多模态生成
那可能还有很多机会
机器人那可能更机会更多
然后包括更夸张的就是有
比如说你能不能用AI
去帮助一些真正的科学问题
比如说帮助这个做
量子调控啊之类的
那可能就是更蓝海
那都是blue sky的事了
对所以说
我觉得对于
足够年轻的人来说
可能做现在最热火的事
并不是一个正确的选择
做现在没有人做到的事
可能更多的是一个好的选择
对
你自己未来会怎么发展
你会在Google很久吗
我觉得应该不会
哈哈哈哈哈哈
这么公开的说吗
我觉得应该不会
我觉得我还是会尝试去挑战自己的
对 然后
要折磨自己
对要折磨自己
但是
我就是可能需要找到一个
值得折磨我自己的事
如果AI不是本质的难的话
你会不会做的觉得无聊啊
你对你的挑战在哪啊
它虽然不难
但是你知道和不知道
还是有一个gap的
就是你从完全不知道这其中细节
到慢慢理解这其中的细节
理解它怎么运作的之类的
这些事情
我觉得还是需要花时间花力气的
然后当你理解之后
我觉得对这个事儿也是会对你未来做
比如不管你是做产品相关
还是说往往别的AI的方向去发展
我觉得都是
都是长期来说
会有帮助的
你未来想在哪里去发展
我觉得都有可能
哈哈哈没想好该怎么折磨自己
你应该不会再跳去另外一个大公司了吧
应该不太会了
嗯
你觉得你在Anthropic上学的
和在Google DeepMind学的有什么不一样
我觉得还是挺不一样
我觉得Anthropic
就是你可以把一个事儿了解
把一条线就是language model
这条线的方方面面的了解的很透
它给你这样的机会
然后在Google
它更多的是一种横向
就是它有很多不同的方面
有很多不一样的人
然后也能见到不一样的视角
也能见到不一样的研究方向
就是你都可以看见
对
Anthropic是因为它bet的足够的坚定
所以你能理解的更纵向
对
你有想过用AI去解决物理问题吗
（你们那个理论物理）有人在干
所以我觉得不需要我去干哈哈
你对这个没有本质的兴趣
我觉得这个事儿
首先
我觉得目前对我来说不是最高优先级
我觉得如果哪天
我觉得
我把我手上最高优先级的事解决了
我又没有找到别的事干
我可能会去干这个事
你现在最高优先级是什么
我现在最高优先级是
就是把我刚才说的这两个事情
哦ml coding和long horizon（能够能够把它）
把它至少推进到一个
就是和同事能够把它
推进到一个比较
我觉得比较稳定的状态吧
那个我觉得是我的最高priority
当然可能之后也会有别的priority
但是
自用AI做物理
我觉得是一个
已经有很多人在试着做的事儿
然后多一个我不多
少一个我不少
不如就让别人先干
你有特别崇拜的物理学家吗
也没有
有 但是有点多
不知从何说起
哈哈哈哈哈
物理学家有
人工智能科学家
没有
但这个跟人的成长经历有关吧
就我觉得
就是
一个成年人是很难真的崇拜一个人的
那一个儿童可能会
崇拜过谁啊
我觉得就物理学
其实还是有很多就真的挺强的
但是就是大家都说的那种什么
100年前那种人就不说了
就什么爱因斯坦
海森伯格这些就不说了
然后包括大家后来都知道
什么像Frank杨
就杨振宁这些也都不说了
然后
像我之前做topology（拓扑）这个体系的时候
其实有一个他后来也拿了诺奖
就是那个Haldane（2016年诺贝尔物理学奖得主之一）
就是你会发现这些人
他有些异常的远见
就是他在他那个时代显得格格不入
但是你看Haldane
最开始做Haldane model和这些分数
量子霍尔效应相关的事的时候
离最后大家搞明白这些拓扑物态
过了好几十年
嗯
在那个时候他能够觉得这事重要
然后一直在自己在推进这事
我觉得这是一个很不容易的
当然我觉得
你要非要在人工智能找一个类似的人
我觉得可能Geoffrey Hinton（杰弗里·辛顿）是吧
就是在大家都觉得这事
可有可无或者不那么确定的时候
他一直在这个方向做
那我觉得
这可能是一个英雄级别的人物
在他之后呢
AI在那之后
我觉得
我觉得可能也有一些英雄的集体
就是比如像Transformer
就 Noam（ Noam Shazeer）
和那些
那个
Ashish（Ashish Vaswani）
Niki（Niki Parmar）他们
那可能是一个英雄集体（Transformer论文的八位作者）
你讲过一个特别让我印象很深的话
我在这个行业又没有什么导师
又没有什么旧友
我想喷谁喷谁
这可能就是不做AI的好处吧
哈哈哈不做AI出身的好处吧
对 就是
真的没有什么负担
就是没有哪个老登是你的亲属
所以你觉得他傻
他就是傻
就可以直接说他傻
没有无所谓的啊
你以前也这样吗
我觉得我做学生的时候还挺收敛的
哦
但我后来发现收敛没用
对自己也没好处
对别人也没好处
还是更直接的
表达自己的想法是最关键的
我觉得直接表达自己的想法
是一个短期一定会有人恨你
但长期大家会欣赏的事情
你最近听谁说话特别蠢
把这个名字哔掉
谢谢
我觉得XXX一直挺蠢的 哈哈哈
而且蠢的始终如一 哈哈哈
他有没有可能是那个对的人呢
我觉得他说的话
用Pauli的话来说就是not even wrong
因为不良好定义
你很难说他说的是对是错
对 就是有一天
可能有一个不一样的范式发生了
他就可以跳出来说哎
我当年说过这个这个这个这个
但是你就发现
可能如果范式是另一种状态
他也能说一样的话
这就是我为什么很讨厌这种很vague（模糊）
很模糊的人的原因
因为一个事模糊就是没有意义的
你为什么觉得他说话很模糊
没有正确的定义
就是
是一种模棱两可
如果它有正确定义的话
我可以解释它为什么有正确定义
但它没有正确定义的话
我没有办法解释
它为什么没有正确定义
因为它真的没有正确定义
哈哈哈
XXX呢
我觉得起码就是
我觉得
XXX还是一个很良好定义的事
就是他是要做XXX
然后他的方式可能更偏这种
更传统的这种
这种neo network的model的方式
而不是更end to end的这种方式
我觉得至少它是良好定义的
至于它是对是错
那我觉得是未来会检验的事情
就大多数老登其实都还好
就是我觉得
我觉得人年纪大了
不一定会变成老登的
人年纪大了会变成两种状态
一种状态叫做德高望重
就是他会可能少指手画脚
还会花自己的力气去培养年轻人
另一种人就是老登
就自己也不懂
还爱指手画脚
嗯所以人老了不一定会变成老登
哎你是受了谁的刺激啊
我也不知道我受了谁的刺激
但我确实见过不少老登
哈哈哈
你从什么时候变化的
就是说话非常直接
开始不收敛了就是你过去都是这么想的
但是你不说
我觉得我过去可能有也会比较直接
但是没有这么直接
但做了AI之后就更直接
是没有没有束缚是吧
一是没有束缚
二是这个领域足够客观
就是
你其实不用太担心
因为自己的观点而惹到什么人
只要你的观点就是是自洽的
就是你有一套自己观点的理论
你不是说随便喷人
那肯定是会惹到别人
你是有一套自己的理解
我觉得其实大家是会尊重你的
因为最终你在这个领域做的怎么样
是有客观的评价标准的
我们每个嘉宾都会推荐一本人生之书
要这本书真的对你产生过重要的影响
你要说的这本书是什么
这是今天最难的一个问题
我感觉你还是高看了我的文化程度
哈哈哈哈哈
我真的没有什么人生之书说实话
好最近读了一本书
最近
上次那个季逸超说的是《线条小狗》
最近读的书就是汤川的自传
汤川秀树（1949年诺贝尔物理学奖得主）的自传啊
《旅人》
然后
非要说就是可能有印象的书
首先我这人确实不爱读书
我感觉就是我这人文化水平比较低
然后我读的书
除了就是专业性的书之外
所有的书感觉都是闲书
像什么汤川的自传
其实本质上也是本闲书
但是就是我觉得写得挺有趣的
就是
你能看到一个
后来看起来如此成功的科学家
在他年轻的时候有一种挣扎感
很真实
然后可能就还有一些什么闲书
像小说之类
有本小说我很喜欢
那个《来自新世界》是一个日本的小说
对我觉得你要非让我推荐闲书的话
我可以推荐那个
你最近有看什么电影啊什么
电视剧 玩什么游戏
什么都没有
哈哈哈
一个全球范围内你喜欢的食物
寿司吧
一个全球范围内你喜欢的地点
全球范围内喜欢的地点
我我觉得现在你要非让我选
我可能会选夏威夷
因为我很喜欢海
对但是也很难说
因为之后我可能去了更多海的地方
就另有新欢了
哈哈哈
一个少有人知道
但是可能需要知道的知识点
别相信老登算吗 哈哈哈
你有迷信过吗
嗯
我
本质上没有迷信过
但是我觉得
有些时候可以靠迷信来安慰自己
我说你有迷信过老登吗
哦迷信老登啊
从来没有吗
真的没有
但是我以前可能没有这么恨老登
后来就变得越来越恨老登
为什么
可能就是
当你自己有越来越多判断的时候
那些蠢的人就显得更蠢
那他们也没有伤害你啊
为什么会恨他呢
就就是厌蠢症
每个人都有厌蠢症
哎你的MBTI是什么
不知道
为什么这些年会有一个对于
就是年轻人
对于年龄大的人
这么不友好的一个词出现啊
它来源在哪里
不知道
没有没有没有
没有研究过
可以问问Gemini
让他deep research一下
看老登这个词是哪来的
那你心目中影响AI进程的几篇论文
sequence to sequence是一篇
然后那个
我觉得是language model
在feature engineering时代的的高峰
然后
Scaling Law是一篇
就是Jared Kaplan
他们在OpenAI的那篇Scaling Law也是一篇
是一篇把这种体系化的研究方式
引进到这个领域的
一篇
当然最后实际上Scaling Law做的方法
可能他那样并不是正确的
就是但是是第一篇
把这个这个想法引进来的
我觉得这很关键
基于你当下的认知
一个关键的重要的bet是什么
long horizon（长程任务）
哈哈哈
我们工作室叫语言即世界工作室
第一次听到这个名字的时候
你在想什么
我觉得这个名字有点
正常的太平庸了
哈哈哈哈哈 可以 哈哈哈哈哈
我觉得这个名字是一个
可能放在十年以前
是一个很独特的视角
那现在可是主要大家共识太多了
我觉得十年以前确实就是
可能现在不止十年
对不起我感觉我年纪也大了
可能不止十年了
就是可能在14 15那个年代
大家都会觉得视觉是最重要的事
在那个时候
我觉得意识到
语言是承载智能的重要载体的人
可能是一个不一样的事情
不过我觉得我们这个名字
不是在AI的语境里面讲的
嗯
哈哈哈
那就值得深思了 哈哈哈